five four three dos uno come on
TriCaster live all right we're live
ladies and gentleman to my left
Tim Tim Poole everybody knows and loves
them Vijay what is it I am pronouncing a
feature
not Vida Vidya the jaw daddy daddy and
your position at Twitter is I lead trust
and safety legal and public policy
that's a lot that's a lot and Jack
Dorsey ladies and gentlemen first of all
thank you everybody for doing this
appreciate it thank you thank you feels
also there's tension in the room just a
few minutes tension and everyone's like
oh this is really happening here we go
before we get started we should say
because there were some things that
people wanted to have us talk about one
that the cash app is one of the sponsors
of the podcast it's been a sponsor for a
long time and also a giant supporter of
my good friend Justin Ren's fight for
the Forgotten charity building wells for
the pygmies in the Congo this is very
important to me and I'm very happy that
you guys are a part of that and you are
connected to that I don't that's I mean
it's easy for someone to say that
doesn't have an influence on the way we
discuss things but it doesn't so if it
does I don't know what to tell you I'm
gonna mention too just because I don't
want people to come out and freak out
later I actually have like 80 shares in
square which isn't really that much in
you know but but it's something it is it
is so I don't want people to think you
know whatever you you're the CEO of
square I think right yep yeah and the
reason why we decided to come together
is we had a I thought a great
conversation last time but there's a lot
of people that were upset that there
were some issues that we didn't discuss
or didn't discuss in-depth enough or
they felt that I didn't press you enough
I talked to Tim because you know Tim and
I have talked before and he made a video
about it and I felt like his criticism
was very valid so we got on the phone
and we talked about it and I knew
immediately within the first few minutes
of the conversation then he was far more
educated about this than I was so I said
would you be willing to do
cast and perhaps do a podcast with Jack
and he said absolutely so we did a
podcast together it was really
well-received people felt like we
covered a lot of the issues that they
felt like I didn't bring up and so then
Jack and I discussed it we said well
let's bring Tim on and then have vigía
on as well I said that right
yeah that's a hard one sorry I'll get
everybody promised but it was so weird
we go um today you know do you know who
Shaun Baker is he's a doctor who's a
prominent proponent of the carnivore
diet his post was his account was frozen
today I just sent it to Jamie yeah his
count was frozen today because of an
image that he had because he's a
proponent of the carnivore diet there's
a lot of people that believe that this
elimination diet is very healthy for you
and it's known to cure a lot of
autoimmune issues with certain people
but some people ideologically opposed it
because they think it's bad for the
environment or you shouldn't eat meat or
whatever the reasons are this is huge in
the Bitcoin community yes
yeah well it's for a lot of people that
have autoimmune issues particularly
psoriasis and arthritis is his lifesaver
it's crazy it's essentially it's an
autoimmune issue so because he has a
photo of a lion in a header eating a
looks like a wildebeest or something
like that his account was locked for
violating these rules rules against
graphic violence or adult content in
profile images that seems a little silly
and I wanted to just mention that right
away now whose decision is something
like that like who decides to lock a
guy's account out because it has a
nature image of you know natural
predatory behavior in this particular
case it's probably an algorithm that
detected it and made some sort of an
assessment but as a general rule how we
operate as a company as we rely on
people to report information to us so if
you look at any tweet you can kind of
pull down on the carrot on the right and
you can say report the tweet and then
you have a bunch of categories you can
choose from what you want to report I
think this one in particular though is
probably an algorithm so how does does
he have the option to protest that or to
ask
to review it absolutely and I'm guessing
that people are already reviewing it but
there's a choice to appeal any action
and that would go to a human to make
sure that it is actually a violation of
the rules or in this case if it's not
then it would be removed is that a
violation the rules that image I don't
think so I don't think that that would
be what we're trying to capture in terms
of graphic images in an avatar it's more
about violence towards humans unless it
was some sort of cruelty depicting
animals or something like that but this
seems not the intention of the rule does
this hi this one of the reason why I
wanted to bring this up immediately does
this highlight a flaw in the system in
that people can target an individual
because with him he's a he like I said
he's a doctor and a proponent of this
carnivore attack but he's also he
ruthless in his condemnation and mocking
of vegans he does it all the time and so
then they get it upset at him and they
can target posts and just report them
and mass and when they do that then this
becomes an issue I think this does
reveal part of you know the challenges
that we face as a global platform at
scale in this but I don't I don't know
what happened in this case sorry it's
hard for me to talk about it but what I
would say is that it doesn't really
matter if one person reports it or
10,000 people report it like we're gonna
review the reports and we're gonna make
an assessment and we're never gonna you
know kick someone off the platform
finally and forever without a person
taking a look and making sure that it's
an actual violation all right okay so
with them but the mob reporting behavior
does happen yeah it does it happens
across the spectrum
I'd have to assume it's gonna be one
direction I can't imagine he would
target vegans but vegans would target
him right well he might I mean he
doesn't but but you see the kind of
guy's gonna want to report to vegans and
get them banned from Twitter where's he
gonna want to make fun of them they're
gonna target him try and get him removed
by exploiting the system that you guys
have
it may not be him though it could also
be his followers it's a really
complicated world out there so yeah you
don't want the more patient's of why
people mob report are different and it's
not always some under someone's control
they could even even be other carnivore
diet proponents who are just jerks that
don't like him because he's getting all
the love people are weird yeah but it's
his sir
the idea though is that it it does kind
of highlight a bit of a flaw in that
it's good that someone can look as you
might see something awful someone daxing
someone or something like that and then
you can take that and report it and then
people can see it and get rid of it and
minimize the damage that's done that
there's another big problem here and
that is the carnivore diet legitimately
healthy is it a threat to your health
and if it is is what is Twitter's
responsibility in controlling that
information right so just to clarify my
my opinion is if you want to be a
proponent for the carnivore diet let
them but you've got people on YouTube
who are being D ranked for certain
beliefs about certain health issues that
I don't agree with and so one of the
risks then is you know we're coming
towards a position where people think
some ideas are better than others
therefore as a company we're going to
restrict access to certain information
you mean like anti vaccine so so I guess
I'm trying to say is at what would you
guys restrict someone from sharing in
fact false information about vaccines
that could get someone hurt that is not
a violation of Twitter's rules no I
think hmm I mean I'd be interested to
hear your ideas around this but our our
perspective right now is around this
concept of variety perspective like are
we are we encouraging more echo chambers
and filter bubbles or we at least
showing people other information that
might be counter to what they see and
there's there's a bunch of research that
would suggest that further emboldened
reviews there's also research that would
suggest that it at least gives up a
consideration about what their what they
currently believe so well you guys know
I sorry given the dynamics of our
network being completely public we're
not organized around communities we're
not organized around topics we have a
little bit more freedom to show more of
the spectrum of any one particular issue
and I think that's how we would we would
approach it from the start that said we
haven't really dealt much with
misinformation more broadly across like
these sorts of topics we've we've
focused our efforts on elections and
well mainly elections right now yeah
YouTube is a different animal you know
someone can really convince you that the
earth is flat if you're gullible and
watch a 45-minute YouTube video right
you know it's kind of a different thing
but I want I wanted to just kind of get
into that statement you made about
misinformation and whether or not you'll
police it so I I think that the tough
part of this is really and love to have
a discussion about this is do you really
want corporations to police what's true
and not true absolutely no that's a
really really tough position what you
guys do that we try not to do that we
don't want to do that when your rules
but the places that we focus on is where
we think that people are going to be
harmed by this in a direct and tangible
way that we feel a responsibility to
correct your rules Tim what you mean by
that naming a misgendering dead naming
and misgender that's a specific ideology
that's unique to a very small faction of
people in this world that you guys
actually ban people for so the way I
think of it is it's behavior based and I
know you think of it as content and we
can we can disagree on this point but
this is about why are you doing this to
a trans person why are you calling them
by this name when they've chosen to go
by a different name or why are you
adding them in some way like what is
your intent and purpose behind that I
mean interrupt but in the interest of
clarity I want to explain what dead
naming means right so well that so a
transgender individual changes their
name when they transition a dead name
would be their birth name or the name
they went by before the transition so
yes my mom is probably going what and an
end of the text what's a dead name and I
will clarify to your rule specifically
targeted misgendering and dead naming I
believe is correct right so years ago we
we passed a policy that we call our
hateful conduct policy and that
prohibits targeting or attacking someone
based on their belonging and any number
of groups whether it's because of their
religion or their race or their gender
their sexual orientation and their
gender identity so it was something
that's broad based is that you you can't
choose to attack people because of these
characteristics but you do have limits
on what characteristics you police right
so you're not you're not banning people
for targeted trans-species others right
well we we have also general abuse and
harassment rules right which says you
can't engage in abuse and harassment on
the plot okay but you can't detonate
someone but you can call them stupid
generally I mean if you created an
account that only was there to call the
same person stupid five thousand times
we'd probably view
as a you know targeted harass targeted
harassment it's a functional it's a
functional behavior like because people
with our system can do this in a massive
velocity so it's ultimately silent you
from a platformer just say like I give
up I don't want to deal with this thing
I'm out
so we can just get into all of the big
examples I mean starting with to Tim but
can we just take a step back and try to
level set what we're trying to do with
our model Seashore I think it's worth
yes yes so as a as a high level I
personally and this is my job to run the
policy team I believe that everyone has
a voice and should be able to use it and
I want them to be able to use it online
now where we draw a line is when people
use their voice and use their platform
to abuse and harass other people to
silence them because I think that that's
what we've seen over the years is a
number of people who have been silenced
online because of the abuse and
harassment they've received and they
either stop talking or they leave the
platform in its entirety if you look at
free expression and free speech laws
around the world they're not absolutely
they're not absolutely there's always
limitations on what you can say and it's
when you're starting to endanger other
people so so my question then is when I
was physically threatened on Twitter you
guys refuse to take down the tweet and I
showed up in Berkeley and someone
physically threatened me because they
were encouraged to when I was in
Venezuela I was physically threatened by
high-profile individual 10,000 people
tweeting at me you guys do nothing right
so I guess there's the obvious question
of why does it always feel like your
policies are going one direction
politically you say it's about behavior
you said several times already but I've
already I've got tons of examples of
that not being the case and you will
always be able to find those examples
examples where you guys were alerted
multiple times and did nothing
like when anti-fat a bunch of law
enforcement agents some of the tweets
were removed but since September this
tweet is still live with a list of
private phone numbers addresses yet
Kathy Griffin she's fine the guy who
threatened the lives of these kids in
Covington and said lock him in the
school and burn it down you did nothing
I mean he got suspended I'd take his
tweets down was he banned for
threatening the lives of kids absolutely
not
so again we have and I'm I'm happy to
talk about all these details we have our
policies that are meant to protect
people and they're meant to enable for
expression as long as you're not trying
to sign
somebody else now we take a variety of
different enforcement mechanisms around
that sometimes you get warned sometimes
we're your tweet is forced to be deleted
it's a very rare occasion where we will
outright suspend someone without any
sort of warning or any sort of ability
to understand what happened what did you
guys do with Kathy Griffin when she was
saying she wanted the names of those
young kids we're in the mag hats at the
Covington high school camps that's right
it's a great example Joe so in that
particular case you know our doxxing
policy really focuses on posting private
information which we don't consider
names to be private we consider your
home address your home from your home
phone number your mobile phone number
those types of things to be private so
in that particular case we took what I
think now is probably a very literal
interpretation of our policy and so that
that was not a daxing incident do you
think that was an error I think that it
was short-sighted and given the context
of what was going on there that if I was
doing this all over again I would
probably ask my team to look at that
through the lens of what was the purpose
behind that tweet and if the purpose was
in fact to identify these kids to either
doxa them or abusing harass them which
it probably was then we should be taking
a more expansive view of that policy and
including that type of content
especially considering the fact they're
minors I would think that right away
that would violate the approach so this
is a trial and error sort of learn and
and move on with new information sort of
a deal absolutely we're gonna learn
we're gonna make a ton of mistakes we're
trying to do this with hundreds of
millions of accounts all around the
world numerous languages we're gonna
make mistakes even if we get better
there will always be mistakes but we're
hoping to learn from those and to make
ourselves better and to catch cases like
Tim's or others where we clearly may
have made an error and I'm open to
having those discussions I'm not I'm
sorry Tim familiar with your specific
cases but I'd love to follow up with you
and we tend to pull it up so it's a bi
te ly slash an tyfa tweet all lowercase
then this is also an evolution in
prioritization as well one of the things
we've come to recently is we do we do
need to we do need to prioritize these
efforts both in terms of policy and
enforcement
however thinking about evolving them one
of the things that we want to focus
as number one is physical safety and
thus lead you immediately to something
like daxing and right now the only way
we take action on a dachshund case is if
it's reported or not what we want to
move to is to be able to recognize those
in real time at least in the english
language
recognize those in real time through our
machine learning algorithms and take the
action before it has to be reported so
we're focused purely right now on going
after dachshund cases with our
algorithms so that we can be proactive
that also requires a much more rigorous
appeals process to correct us when we're
wrong
but we think it's tightly scoped enough
it impacts the most important thing
which is someone's physical safety once
we learn from that we can really look at
the the biggest issue with our system
right now is all the burden is placed
upon the victim so we only act based on
reports we don't show a lot of
enforcement especially with with more of
the more of more of the takedowns that
are run through a machine learning
algorithm deep learning algorithm but if
something is reported a human does
review it eventually or are there a
series of reports that you never get to
there's there's probably reports we
don't I mean we we prioritize the queue
based on severity and the thing that one
mark severity is something like physical
safety or private information or not so
generally we try to get through
everything but we have to prioritize
that queue even coming in so if someone
threatened the lives of someone else you
would you banned that account would you
tell them like like let's say someone
tweeted three times kill these people I
want them dead three times is that yes
that's a violation you didn't ban him
though Jamie that's uh I don't know I
don't necessarily want to give out
specific usernames because then that
people just point the finger at me and
say I'm getting these people banned but
yeah you know during Covington this guy
said multiple times - he wanted his
followers to go and kill these kids yeah
and we have to look at that but we also
look in the context because we also have
I think we talked about this a little
bit in the last podcast but we we have
gamers on the platform who are saying
exactly that to their friends that
they're going to meet at the game in the
game tonight and without the context of
that relationship without the context of
the conversation that we're having we
would
take the exact same action on them
incorrectly yeah absolutely that I
understand I think in the case of
Covington though this user was so
high-profile
he's a verified user he's got something
like 20,000 followers and it was
highlighted by numerous conservative
media outlets saying wow this guy's it's
screenshotted it's being shared I mean
you had a disney producer in like saying
a picture of the wood chipper with a
body being thrown in it saying that's
what he wanted to happen you know I I do
know that some of these accounts got
lodged isn't he producer was that well
I'll clarify fact check me on that but
that's the basically the conversation
that was had there's a guy Disney was he
posted a picture from Fargo of someone
being tossed in a wood chipper and he
says I want all these manga kids you
know done like this you had another guy
who specifically said lock them in the
school burn it down said a bunch of
disparaging things and then said if you
see them fire on them and he tweeted
that more than once and that those
accounts were those tweets were taken
down those were violations of our rules
I'm pretty sure it's actually illegal to
do that right it's to to tell your any
individual to commit a felony is a crime
like right incitement of violence I
serve in many places I just have to
wonder how I understand the context
issue but this is what this is what I
talk what was common scale too though
right but Tim those accounts were
auctioned they may not have been action
the way you wanted to them to but the
the tweets were forced to be deleted and
that camera shows a penalty for that so
I understand that penalty well again as
I said earlier Joe we don't usually
automatically suspend accounts with one
violation because we want people to
learn we want people to understand what
they did wrong and give them an
opportunity not to do it again right and
it's it's a big thing to kick someone
off the platform and I take that very
very seriously so so I want to make sure
that when someone creates our rules they
understand what happened and they're
given an opportunity to you know get
back on the platform and change their
behavior and so in many of these cases
what happens is we will force someone to
acknowledge that their tweet violated
our rules force them to delete that
tweet before they can get back on the
platform and in in many cases if they do
it again we give them a timeout which is
like seven days when we say look you've
done it again it's a temporary
suspension if you do a timeout you're a
mom
and you monitor and if you do it again
then you're done so it's kind of like
you know three strikes so sort of like
baseball and so in some of these cases
that Tim is referencing I have to
imagine cuz these sweets were deleted
they are violations of our rules people
are upset that the account came back
again and was allowed to say other
things but we did take action on those
streets they were violations and then
you have people like Milo who was mean
to a person and you delete you banned
him permanently there's more I'm happy
to talk about Milo and I actually
brought the tweets because so let's
let's preface that by saying the point I
want to make sure is clear is that you
had somebody who actively called for the
death of people I understand the context
issue maybe he's talking about video
games probably talk some scale and scale
so this is a verified user and it's not
just the complexity and enacting not an
excuse for why we didn't do it in
particular right and then there are a
lot of other examples too like in to
more egregious areas that I've prepared
so here we have someone with over 20,000
followers he's verified numerous times
incites his followers to commit a crime
against these kids the action taken
against him is believed the tweets you
get a suspension you get timeout then
you have people like Alex Jones who
berated a CNN reporter permanently
banned you get Miley innopolis he was
mean permanently banned but that's your
impression that's not what happened okay
let's do this one at a time let's start
with Milo what was the details of Milo
so Milo had a number of tweets that
violated our rules going back to 2014
but I'm going to talk about the final
three in this research concept he
claimed to be a BuzzFeed reporter in his
bio and he's a verified account so that
is impersonation I'm not sure why he did
that he did do that
well BuzzFeed's a left-wing thing so he
was doing parody potentially but our
parody rules are very specific that if
you have an account that's me being as a
parody account you need to say that it
is a parody account right people
everybody who knows Milo would know that
he's not a BuzzFeed reporter but people
who don't know Milo will look at that it
wasn't verified after a while you
removed his verification he violated our
rules or a certification so the viable
via the verification was removed because
of the BuzzFeed thing I believe so I can
confirm that I believe so he also docked
someone he posted private information
about an individual so that was the
second one mm-hmm he tweeted to somebody
else if you were my child I'd have
dashed her head on a rock and tried
again which we viewed as a threat really
mm-hmm that seems like he's saying like
your mom should have swallowed you you
know it's like you know I'm saying he's
like you're a mistake that's a threat I
understand what reasonable people would
have different impressions this I'm just
going through and telling you what they
are just really have all the facts
debate them and then the last one we
found a bunch of things that he posted
that we viewed as incitement of abuse
against Leslie Jones so there's a bunch
of them but the one that I like to look
at which really convinced me is he
posted two doctored tweets that were
supposedly by Leslie Jones they were
fake tweets the first one said white
people are getting on my nerves like how
can you call yourself human and then the
second one said the goddamn slur for a
Jewish person at Sony ain't paid me yet
dan Bicks nude better pay up so this was
just a fake tweet that someone had
photoshopped to fake tweets and we know
they were faked because we could still
tell from the software and then they
were faked is you can't always tell so
it is it is possible that he didn't know
they were faked it's possible someone
sent it to him and he didn't do his due
diligence and looking it up and it is
possible but it was pointed out to him
that they were fake because he left it
on and not only did he leave it on he
said don't tell me some mischievous
Internet rascal made them up exclamation
point so this in the context of a bunch
of other things he was saying towards
Leslie Jones on Twitter I and my team
felt that this was taken as a whole
incitement of harassment against her
wasn't there another issue with multiple
accounts that were connected to him
there were a bunch of other issues on
the background but these are the three
primary things that we looked at in
terms of the other things that were in
the background
with a multiple accounts that were
connected to him like I think that I'm
not sure about that Joe
I think it was more that we found him to
be engaging in coordinated behavior and
inciting people to to attack Leslie
Jones now with a case with like him no
I'm just gonna be honest what I'm
listening to those or listening to read
those tweets out they don't sound that
bad and they certainly don't sound as
bad as calling for the death of a child
was wearing a maggot hat throw him into
a wood chipper the fact that that guy
still out there
tweeting and yet Milo's not Milo's
initial the whole thing stemmed from
other than the BuzzFeed thing stemmed
from his legitimate criticism of a film
and he's you know he's a satirist he was
mocking this film the daxing incident
wasn't related why don't we we all agree
that daxing is something that should
take action hundred percent Retton
people in real life and i take an
enormous amount of responsibility for
that because I fear Daly for the things
that are happening on the platform that
are translating into the real world so
Milo is a contentious figure and there's
certainly things you can pull up that I
wouldn't agree with anything he did
there I think those are horrible I think
Joe brought some really good points but
what about Chuck Johnson why was Chuck
Johnson banned I don't have those
details in front of me Chuck Johnson
said that he was preparing something to
take out DeRay McKesson and in the
journalistic context people take this to
mean he was going to do a dossier or
some kind of hit piece under a his
permanently banned and my understanding
and it's been a long time since I've
read this there was some leaked emails I
think from Dick Costolo where he said
maybe it wasn't Dec I want a dragged
dick I don't know who it was exactly
they said I don't care just get rid of
him and he was off so you have and again
maybe there's some hidden context there
I don't know but on the surface the
concern is that this is always leaning
towards the left oh it absolutely is and
I'm I'm not even getting started yeah I
can understand why you feel that way I
don't think that's true I think we look
at each individual instance of
violations or our rules and try to make
the best case that we can well not
trying and I do think Jo just to just to
say I do think we've failed in a couple
of ways and I want to admit that
number one we haven't done enough
education about what it rules are
because a lot of people violate our
rules and they don't even know it like
some of the statistics that we've looked
at like for a lot of first-time users of
the platform if they violate the rule
once almost two-thirds of them never
violate the rules again so we're not
talking about like a bunch of people
accidentally like if they know what the
rules are most people can avoid it and
most people when they feel the sting of
a violation they go okay I don't want to
lose my rights to post exactly and
they're able to do it so we have a lot
of work to do on education so people
really understand what the rules are in
the first place the other thing we have
to do to address these allegations that
we're doing this from a biased
perspective is to be really clear about
what types of behavior are caught by our
rules and what types are not and to be
transparent within the product so when a
particular tweet is found to be in
violation of our rules being very very
clear like this tweet was found to be in
violation of this particular rule and
that's all work that we're doing is we
think the combination of Education and
transparency is really important
particularly for an open platform like
Twitter it's just part of who we are and
we have to build it into the product I
appreciate that your particular thoughts
though on those examples that he
described when he talking about
someone saying he should throw these
children into a wood chipper versus
Chuck Johnson saying he should take this
guy he wants to prepare a dossier to
take this guy out or how did he say it
he said something like I'm gonna take
out DeRay McKesson with he said I'm
preparing to take out Eric something
like that I can't preparing I know I can
understand it could be misconstrued as
he was trying to assassinate him right
could you could misconstrue with that
but not a direct but the other ones a
direct threat one guy is banned for life
the other guy is still post and we can
I'm happy to follow up I just don't have
all the Chuck Johnson it's not about one
thing is it it's about a pattern and
practice of violating rules and we we
don't want to kick someone off for one
thing but if there's a pattern in
practice like there was from Milo we are
gonna have to take action at some point
because we can't sit back and let people
be abused and harassed and silenced on
the problem well so so one really
important thing that needs to be stated
is that Twitter by definition is a
biased platform in favor of the left
period it's not it's not a question I
understand you might have your own
interpretation but it's very simple
conservatives do not agree with you on
the definition of misgendering if you
have a rule in place that specifically
adheres to the left ideology you by
default are enforcing
from a biased perspective what's him
there are a lot of people on the Left
who don't agree with how we're doing our
job either for sure and those people
think that we don't take enough action
on abuse harassment and we let far too
much behavior go anything but that's a
radical example though I mean what he's
talking about I mean in terms of
generalities that in general things lean
far more left would you agree that I
don't know what that means but in this
particular case it's how the speech is
being used that this is a new vector of
attack that people have felt that I
don't want to be on this platform
anymore because I'm being harassed and
abuse and I need to get the hell out
well people harass and abused me all day
and I don't do anything about that
my note efficacious permanently locked
at 99 you have a worse than I do I mean
you got substantially more followers and
I don't click the notification tab
anymore because it's basically just
harassment and I even when so this is a
really funny anecdote I was covering a
story in Berkeley and someone said if
you see him attack him like it was it
was I'm paraphrasing they said basically
to swing at me take my stuff steal from
me and Twitter told me after review was
not a violation of their policy somebody
made an allusion to me being a
homosexual and I reported that instantly
gone so when I show so so for me I'm
looking I'm like well of course of
course Twitter is going to enforce the
social justice aspect of their policy
immediately in my opinion probably
because you guys have PR constraints and
you're probably nervous about that but
when someone actually threatens me with
a crime and incites their followers to
do it nothing got done I'm not the only
one who feels that way what Tim that's a
mistake
if someone acts in that manner and
threatens to hurt you that's a violation
of our rules right maybe there was a
mistake there and I'm happy to go and
correct that and we can do it offline so
we don't fear any sort of reprisal
against you but that's a mistake that's
not an agenda on my part or in the team
spark would this be I don't know of any
PR constraints that is not so why did
you ban Alex Jones do you want to get
into that absolutely sure all right
well let me say this the reason I bring
him up is that Oliver Darcy one of the
lead reporters covering Alex Jones and
his content said on CNN that it was only
after media pressure did these social
networks take action so that's why I
bring him up specifically because it
sort of implies you were under
your constraints to get rid of him I
think if you look at the PR that's what
I went through in that incident it
wouldn't be that we looked good in it
you have and that's not at all why we
took action you have to look at the full
context in the spectrum there because
one of the things that happened over a
weekend is what Alex mentioned on your
on your podcast with him he was removed
from the iTunes podcast directory that
was the that was the lynchpin for him
because it drove all the traffic to what
he said basically zero immediately after
that we saw our pure company's Facebook
Spotify YouTube also take action we did
not we did not because we when we looked
at our service and we looked at the
reports on their service we did not find
anything in violation of our rules then
we got into a situation where suddenly a
bunch of people were reporting content
on our platform including CNN who wrote
an article about all the things that
might violate our rooms rules that we
looked into and we gave him one of the
other warnings and then we can get into
the the actual details but yeah we did
not follow we we resisted just being
like a domino with our peers because it
wasn't consistent with our rules and
with the contract we put in before our
customers so what was it that made you
ban so there were three separate
incidents that came to our attention
after the fact that were reported to us
by by different users there was a video
that was uploaded that showed a child's
being violently thrown to the ground and
crying so that was the first one the
second one was a video that we viewed as
incitement of violence I can read it to
you it's a little it's a little bit of a
transcripts but um but now it's time to
act on the enemy before they do a false
flag I know the Justice Department's
crippled a bunch of followers and
cowards but there's groups there's grand
juries there's you called for it it's
time politically economically and
judiciously and legally and criminally
to move against these people it's got to
be done now get together the people you
know aren't traitors aren't cowards
aren't helping their frickin bets
hedging their [ __ ] bets like all these
other [ __ ] do
let's go let's do it so people need to
have their and then there's a bunch of
other stuff but at the end so people
need to have their battle rifles ready
and everything ready at their bedsides
and you've got to be ready because the
media is so disciplined in their
deception so this is you're saying that
this is a call to violence against the
media that's what it sounded like to us
at the time and there have been a number
of incidents of violence against the
media and again I take my responsibility
for what happens on a platform and how
that translates off platform very
seriously and that felt like it was an
incitement of I know if he only tweeted
the incitement to violence he would've
been fine if he only if he only tweeted
that trends posted that transcript
saying get your battle fire rifles ready
you wouldn't have deleted his account
again context matters Tim it's not about
one thing so we'd have to look at the
entire context of what's going on so I'm
asking was that was that egregious
enough for you to say that alone that
wasn't wasn't number two right right so
then I guess the question is what was
the video context of the kid being
thrown to the ground
was it newsworthy we obviously didn't
think so and depicting violence against
a child is not something that we would
allow on the platform even if it's news
content if it was there are certain
types of situations where if you were
reporting on you know war zone and
things that might be happening we would
put an interstitial on that type of
content that's graphic or violent but we
didn't feel that that was the context
here well so there's a video that's been
going around that was going around few
four or five weeks ago the one where the
the girls were yelling at that big giant
guy and the guy punched that girl in the
face and she was like 11 years old I saw
that multiple times on Twitter that was
one of the most violent things that were
seeing this giant man punched this
eleven-year-old girl in the face and
that was was that removed from Twitter I
don't know I would have to go see if
anyone reported it to us I think one of
the issues here is to is you know you
want me to get to the third one yeah so
the third strike that we looked at was a
verbal altercation that Alex got into
with a journalist and in that
altercation there were which was
uploaded to Twitter there were a number
of statements using eyes of the rat even
more evil looking person he's just scum
or a virus to America and freedom
smelling like a possum that climbed out
of the rear end of a dead cow you look
like a possum that got caught doing some
really really nasty stuff in my view
there was a bunch of that's enough
really that's hilarious
pattern in practice but it was a verbal
altercation that was posted on your ass
oh so so we took the totality of this
I've been warned that we have rules
against abuse and harassment of
individuals we saw this pattern in
practice one strike two strike three
strikes and we made a decision to
permanently and so that last one was on
periscope is that what it was that he
broadcast through I think it was
originally on periscope but it was also
reposted from multiple related accounts
onto Twitter so we can we can agree with
you when you say these things like you
know Alex said this it sounds like a
threat he was berating this person
saying awful things but ultimately your
judgement is the contact you say we have
to pay attention the context we're just
trusting that you made the right
decision well I'm I'm giving you as much
fast as I can give you here and I think
that this is the real hard part of
content moderation at scale on global
platforms it's not easy and I don't
think Jack or I would tell you that it's
easy it's an imposter assume you guys
have to deal with and that's one of the
ones that I wanted to get into with Jack
when I first had him on because when my
thought and I wasn't as concerned about
the censorship as many people were my
main concern was what is it like to
start this thing that's kind of for fun
and then all of a sudden it becomes the
premier platform for free speech on the
planet Earth so let me just it is that
but it's also a platform that's used to
abusing harass a lot of people and used
in ways that none of us want it to be
used but unless it happens do so and I
think it's an enormous ly complicated
challenge for any company to do content
moderation at scale and that's something
that we are sitting down thinking about
how do we take this forward because this
is it doesn't go so so let's let's take
the other context now we've heard what
you said why what Alex Jones did was bad
and now we can look at it this way
Oliver Darcy who has on numerous
occasions insulted conservatives
recently on CNN called them gullible
being sold red and meat by grifters
repeatedly covers a story I'm gonna do
air quotes because I think to an extent
he's allowed to cover these stories he
keeps going after Alex Jones he keeps
digging through his history then he goes
on TV and says we got him banned then
Alex Jones confronts him in a
very aggressive and mean way and that's
your justification for it or I should
say I invert the timeline basically you
have someone who's relentlessly digging
through stuff insulting you you know
calling you names
sifting through your history trying to
find anything they can to get you
terminated going on TV even writing
numerous stories you confront them and
say you're evil and you say a bunch of
really awful mean things and then you
ban him right so when you post that
information and all over the Internet
right but you have a journalist who
recently went on TV and said CPAC is a
bunch of gullible conservatives being
fed red meat buy grifters you can tell
this guy's not got honest an honest
agenda so what you have it to me it
looks like the Conservatives to an
extent probably will try and mass flag
people on the left but from an
ideological standpoint you have the
actual you know whatever people want to
call it sect of identitarian left that
believe free speech is a problem that
have literally shown up in Berkeley
burning free speech signs and then you
have conservatives who are tweeting mean
things and the Conservatives are less
likely in I think it's fair to point out
less likely to try and get someone else
banned because they like playing off
them and the left is is targeting them
so you end up having disproportion a lot
of assumptions and what you're saying
and I don't know what basis you're
saying those things I mean you have
conservatives demanding free speech and
you have liberals I shouldn't say
liberals you have what people refer to
as the regressive left calling for the
restrictions on speech you have these I
don't know what those terms mean to be
honest with you we have people on all
sides of the spectrum who believe in
free speech and I'm I believe that to be
the case so your platform restricts
speech our platform promotes speech
unless people violate our rules and in a
specific direction in any direction but
uncle I don't want to say his name the
guy who calls for death gets a
suspension the guy who insinuates that
gets a permanent ban but Tim you're
you're misinterpreting what I'm saying
and I feel like you're doing it
deliberately it's not about one
particular thing it's about a pattern
and practice of violating you have
shattered and practice of banning only
one faction of people recently published
an article where they looked at 22
high-profile bandings from 2015 and
found 21 of them were only on one side
of the cultural debate but I don't look
at the political spectrum of people when
I'm looking at their to write you you
have a yes they are you're biased and
you're
targeting specific individuals because
your rules support this perspective no
well so can you be clear though and like
what rules support that person
specifically the the easiest one is
misgendering right because that's so
clearly ideological if you ask a
conservative what is misgendering
they'll say if someone is biologically
male and you call them you know a
biological man you called a machine
that's miss gender as a conservative
view the the the progressive view is
inverted so now you actually have in
your policies a a rule against the
conservative perspective I have a rule
against the abuse and harassment of
trans people on our platform that's what
at my rules we just give context in the
background I know why that is and I
brought some some research so we
obviously received a lot of feedback so
we don't make these rules in a vacuum it
just to be clear we have a bunch of
people all around the world who give us
context and the types of behavior
they're seeing how that translates into
real-world harm and they give us
feedback and they tell us like you
should consider different types of rules
different types of perspectives
different like for example when we try
to enforce hateful conduct in our
hateful conduct policy in a particular
country we're not going to know all the
slur words that are used to target
people of a particular race or a
particular religion so we're going to
rely on building out a team of experts
all around the world who are going to
help us enforce our rules so in the
particular case of misgendering I'm just
trying to pull up some of the studies
that we looked at but we looked at the
American Association of Pediatrics and
looked at the number of transgender
youths that were committing suicide it's
an astronomical I'm sorry I can't find
it right now in front of me it's a
really really high statistic that's like
10 times what the normal suicide rate is
of normal teenagers and we looked at the
causes of what that was happening and a
lot of it was not just violence towards
those individuals but it was bullying
behavior and what was what were those
bullying behaviors that were
contributing to that and that's why we
made this rule because we thought and we
believed that those types of behaviors
were happening on our platform and we
wanted to stop it now there are
exceptions to this rule we don't and
this is all it this isn't about like
public figures and there's always gonna
be public figures that you're gonna want
to talk about and that's
it's fine but this is about are you
doing something with the intention of
abusing and harassing a trans person on
the platform and are they viewing it
that way and reporting it to us so that
we take action so so I will just state I
actually agree with the rule I'm from
you know my point of view I agree that
bullying and harassing trans people is
entirely entirely wrong I disagree with
it but I just want to make sure it's
clear to everybody who's listening my
point is simply that you know ben
shapiro went on a talk show and
absolutely refused and that's his shake
you know and he's one of the biggest
podcasts in in the world so if you have
all of his millions upon millions of
followers who are looking at this rule
saying this goes against my view of the
world and it's literally 60 plus million
in this country you do have a rule
that's ideologically bent and and it's
it's true you you did the research you
believe this well then you have been
shapiro who did his research and doesn't
believe it and I relied on the American
Association of Pediatrics and you know
Human Rights Council another and I'm
sure he has his sources too for when he
gives his statements the point is he's
wonder if they have that context I mean
that's and that's where we have also
fits it's it's always just explaining
the why behind a lot of our policy
reasons I I would agree and I think it's
fine you did research and you found this
to be true but we can't simply say maybe
ben shapiro and the other conservatives
who feel this way don't know we have to
wait we can't you know the point i'm
trying to make is it's it's simply
whether you believe it but whether you
justified or not is not the point the
point is you do you do have this rule
that rule is at odds with conservatives
period well i think i think that you're
you're generalizing but i think it is
really important as Jack said to the why
behind these things the why is to
protect people from abuse and harassment
on our pot I understand but you
essentially created a protected class if
this is the case because despite these
studies and what you know these studies
are showing there's a gigantic suicide
rate amongst trans people period it's a
forty percent it's it's outrageously
large now whether that is because of
gender dysphoria with us because of the
complications from sexual surgery sexual
transition surgery whether it's because
of bullying whether it's because of this
awful feeling of being born in the wrong
gender whether that all that is yet to
be determined
the fact that they've shown that there's
a large amount of trans people that are
committing suicide I don't necessarily
think that that makes that makes sense
in terms of people from someone's
perspective like a ben shapiro saying
that if you are biologically female if
you were born with a double x chromosome
you will never be XY if he says that
that's that's a violation of your policy
and this is you're creating a protected
class to be to be fair press that
opinion she was easily entitled to
express that opinion if he's doing in a
manner that's targeted at an individual
repeatedly and saying that okay but you
know what's going on with martina
navratilova right now martina
navratilova
why am i can i say her last name neither
yeah never tried on't think i've ever
said it
martina navratilova is it tall over
troll over anyway epic world class but
legend tennis player right who happens
to be a lesbian is being harassed
because she says that she doesn't
believe that trans women means someone
who is biologically male who transitions
to a female should be able to compete in
sports against biological females this
is something that i agree with this is
something i have personally experienced
a tremendous amount of harassment
because i stood up when there was a
woman who was a trans woman who was
fighting biological females in mixed
martial arts fights and destroying these
women and i was saying what you just
watch this and tell me this doesn't look
crazy to you well I got good well my
point is you should be able to express
yourself in if you say that you believe
someone is biologically male even though
they identify as a female that's a
perspective that should be valid I mean
that this is someone's someone's this is
first of all it's biologically correct
so we have a problem in that if your
standards and your policies are not
biologically accurate then you're
dealing with an ideological
you know an ideological policy and just
because I mean I don't I don't want to
target trans people I don't want to
harass them I certainly I'll call
anybody whatever they want I mean if you
want to change your name to a woman's
name and identify as a woman I'm a
hundred percent cool with that but by
saying I don't think that you should be
able to compete as a woman this opens me
up for harassment now I never ordered
any of it I just don't pay attention to
it but in going into like Megan Murphy
for instance right you can call that
target harassment if Megan Murphy who is
for those that are don't know she's a
radical feminist who refuses to use the
transgender pronouns if she's in an
argument with a trans person over
whether or not they should be allowed in
sports or in biologically female spaces
and she refuses to use their pronoun
because of her ideology
you'll ban them again it depends on the
context on the platform and it's also I
want not banned permanently like you get
one she was banned permanently but let's
say she was warned about what happened
to me what did she actually do my
understanding and I don't have the tweet
by tweet the way that I did for the
others but my understanding is that she
was warned multiple times for
misgendering an individual that she was
in an argument with and this individual
is actually bringing a lawsuit against
her in Canada as well so it is you have
an argument between two people again and
you have a rule that enforces only one
side of the ideology and you've banned
only one of those people we have a rule
that attempts to address what we have
perceived to be instances of abuse or
harassment ideology is an ideology right
if she's saying a man is never a woman
if that's what she's saying and then
biologically she's correct we obviously
have a debate here this is not a
clear-cut this is not something like you
can say water is wet you know this is
dry it's and this is not like something
you could prove this is something where
you you have to acknowledge that there's
an understanding that if someone there's
a trans person we all agree to consider
them a woman and to think of them as a
woman to talk to them and address them
with their preferred name and their
preferred pronouns but biologically this
is not accurate so
we have we have a divide here we have a
divide between the conservative
estimation of what's happening and then
the definition that's the liberal
definition of it I think that's right
Joe and I think what I'm trying to say
is that it's not that you can't have
those viewpoints it's a if you're taking
those viewpoints and you're targeting
about them at a specific person in a way
that reflects your intent to abuse and
harass them what if it's in the context
of the conversation what if she's saying
that I don't think that trans women
should be allowed in these female spaces
to make decisions for women and then
this person's arguing and she says a
woman is biologically female you are
never going to be a woman she responded
with men aren't women though and that
was her first in the series of events
that's what got her the suspension in
the warning that was one of many tweets
that were part of providing context and
that was actually the second second
actually strike is my understanding but
why is that a strike yeah why is that a
strike that but again like it's the
context of I don't I don't have all the
tweets in front of me there were like 10
or 12 tweets going back and forth mm-hmm
and my understanding is that in that
context of all of those she was
misgendering a particular person not
that she was holding a purse it wasn't
it I don't know it was so you know
you're having you're having an
individual who was debating a high
profile individual in her community and
she's expressing her her ideology of
versus hers and you have opted to ban
one of those ideologies it's within the
context of this conversation yes is this
is what is being debated whether or not
someone is in fact a woman when they
were born a male I understand that this
is controversial I I do especially to a
radical feminist I understand why why
people would not agree with the role but
that being said it is a rule on our
platform and once you're warned about
the rule to repeatedly post the same
content is also going to be a violation
of our rules rabbit the rule it's this
seems like a good example of an
ideologically based rule if yours if
she's saying that a man is never a woman
though that is not in that context
harassment that is a very specific
opinion that she has that happens to be
biologically accurate now I don't you
know I don't agree with targeting
harassment on anybody and I did
harassment on trans people or or
straight people or when I
I don't I don't agree with it I don't
think you should do it it's just it's
not something I want to do but in this
context what she's saying is not just
her expression but it's accurate I think
an important point is if I tweet it to
you jo-jo you are not a hamster that's
clearly not a violation of the rules
however there are identify as a hamster
well no it wouldn't be clear because I
know I know people who have specifically
begun using insults of animals to avoid
getting kicked off the platform for
breaking the rules certain individuals
have been suspended now use certain
small woodland creatures in place of
slurs so they're not really insulting
you and it's fine but there are people
who consider themselves trans-species
now I'm not trying to belittle the trans
community by no means I'm just trying to
point out that you have a specific rule
for one set of people and they're there
so there are people who have general
body dysphoria you don't have rules on
that there are people who have actually
amputated their own arms you don't have
rules on that you have a very specific
rule set and in more importantly in the
context of a targeted conversation I can
say a whole bunch of things that would
never be considered a rule break but
that one is which is ideologically
driven yeah thank you for the feedback I
mean we're we're again always learning
and trying to understand different
people's perspectives and all I'll say
is that our intent is not to police
ideology our intent as to police
behaviors that we view as abuse movement
harassment and I hear your point of view
and it's something that I'll definitely
discuss with my team and even in this
case it wasn't just a going against this
particular rule but also things that
were more ban evasive as well including
taking a screenshot of the original
tweet reposting it which is against her
our Terms sir well that sounds so it's
more objections it sounded like a
protest against your rule but I
understand you could ban them for it but
people can protest any of our rules we
can't we can't like let them do that no
no I understand we were saying but I
just want to make sure I point out she
was clearly doing it as an effort to
push back on what she viewed as an
ideologically driven rule well this is
that the problem is this is a real
debate in the LGBT community this is a
debate where there is a division and
there's a division between people that
think that trans women are in
evading biological female spaces and
making decisions that don't benefit
these biological females cisgender
whatever you want to call them this is
an actual debate and it's a debate
debate amongst progressive people
amongst left-wing people and it's a
debate amongst liberals this is I mean I
would imagine the vast majority of
people in the LBGT community are in fact
on the left and this is one example of
that so you have a protected class
that's having an argument with a woman
who feels like there's an ideological
bent to this conversation that is not
not only not accurate but not fair and
she feels like it's not fair for
biological women the same as Martina
well Allah take this to its logical
conclusion I got sent a screenshot from
somebody and maybe it's faked I think it
was real they were having an argument
with someone on Twitter and responded
with dude , you don't know blah blah
blah and they got a suspension and a
lockout had delete the tweet because the
individual using a cartoon avatar with
the eight with the nickname with
apparently with Sam reported it and said
that I'm transgender and he's calling me
dude and the dude and the Twitter user
actually got a suspension for it so I
could understand mistakes happen but
when you have a rule that's like that
there's colloquial terms that are like
man come on don't say that dude is like
we say like like I asked you guys when
you were gonna take a photo in front of
this thing I said guys but I included
you and I didn't I wasn't offended you
and I we're never reported you for it
thank you yeah it's it's tricky but in
this case of Megan Murphy that's her
name right yeah yeah I did that doesn't
make any sense to me that seems like she
should be allowed to express herself in
and this is this is not being she's not
being mean by saying a man is never a
woman this is a perspective that just
that is scientifically accurate and
that's that's part of the problem I
think I just don't want to run to a
beating a dead horse so I think I want
to it's a really important thing to go
over all the nuances of this particular
subject because I think that one in
particular highlights this idea of where
the problems lie and having a protected
class and I think should be
compassionate we have a lot of protected
classes gender race nationality look
these are the protector
it's not for white people when you say
gender or race when it's not all
protected categories so you can't attack
someone for their belonging to a
particular race or a particular religion
only you can mock white people ad
nauseam it's not a problem it doesn't
get it doesn't get removed I'm not
talking about mocking I'm talking about
abusing and harassing but I mean if you
mock a black person in the same way it
would be considered targeted racism
again it's about targeted harassment on
the platform well target Rassman I mean
but when you're okay look if you have
what is racism is is racism only I mean
there's this progressive perspective of
racism that it's only possible if you're
from a more powerful class it's only
punching down that's the only racism I
don't think that makes any sense
I think racism is looking at someone
that is from whatever whatever race and
deciding that they are in fact less or
less worthy or less valuable whatever it
is that that takes place across the
platform against white people now I'm
not saying white people need to get
protected I know it's easier being a
white person in America the fact but
it's hypocritical to have a policy that
only distinguishes you can make fun of
white people all day long but if you
decide to make fun of Asian folks or you
know fill in the blank that is racist
but making fun of white people isn't and
it doesn't get removed there are tons of
chuckling about sarah jong from the new
york times that's a well I can actually
explain that one please do that was my
understanding is that you guys started
banning people officially under these
policies around 2015 and most all the
tweets she made was prior to that and so
you didn't enforce the old yeah so our
hateful conduct policy judges to be
clear is is across the board meaning
like it doesn't just protect women and
protects men and women it protects all
races it doesn't matter and this is how
the law is set up in the United States
right you can't discriminate against
white men you can't discriminate against
black men like those are the laws right
like that's the structure it is it
doesn't it doesn't take into consider so
if someone says something about white
people and mocks white people on Twitter
what do you do about that if it's
targeted harassment targeted at a person
so John why pee
in general if you say something about
white people in general that's not an
issue well I mean we focus on targeted
harassment which is behavior that is
targeted against an individual who
belongs to that class okay
because if you try to police every
opinion that people have about different
races or religions thinking obviously
that's a very different story so this is
about if you target that to somebody who
belongs to that class and that's
reported to us that is a violation of
our rules and so in the Sarah Jeon case
a lot we did see many tweets of that
nature that were focused on people who
were white or men and our rules in this
area came into effect in 2015 which was
our hateful conduct policy and a lot of
those tweets were from a time period
where those rules weren't enough and in
her defense she was actually supposedly
responding to people that have you don't
believe that come on over three years
and she's tweeting blankets yes sure
sure but so so I will say - obviously
I've done it my one point so in that
case there were tweets from before the
rules went into effect and tweets from
after the rules went into effect and we
did take action on the tweets from after
the rules went into she's also pretty
young but right so I want to point yeah
she's in her 20s yeah so we're talking
about something that might have happened
eight years ago right right 20 it was
like 2011 but but I do want to point
this out before coming on I've obviously
did it I did a decent amount of research
I searched for slurs against white
people black people Latinos and I found
copious just just tons and tons of them
now they don't go back most of what I
found didn't go back too far cause it
does seem like you guys are doing your
best but there's a lot and it targets
white people black people Jewish people
it's everywhere and I can understand
that you guys you got hundreds of
millions but let's let's let's let's try
another subject just just to address
that point and I think Jack talked about
this a little bit like this is where
right now we have a system that relies
on people to report it to us which is a
huge burden on people and especially if
you're happen to be a high profile
person and Tim you would you would
understand this you're not gonna sit
there and report every tweet and Joe you
understand this story like it's not
worth your time you're not gonna go
through a tweet by tweet as people
respond to you and report it people tell
us this all the time so this is where we
have to start getting better at eye
identifying when this is happening and
taking action on it without waiting for
somebody to tell us it's out but using
an algorithm though do you not miss
context I mean it seems to me that
there's a lot of people that say things
in humor you know the or slurs within
particular communities which is
perfectly reasonable right right so yes
there is a danger of the algorithm is
missing context and that's why we really
want to go carefully into this and this
is why we scoped it down first and
foremost to doxing which is at least
first it's our number one goal
protecting physical safety like making
sure that nothing done online will
impact someone's physical safety Holland
offline on our platform in in this case
the second is that there are patterns
around daxing that are much easier to
see without having the context there are
there are exceptions of course because
you could Docs someone's public you know
a representatives public office phone
number and email address and the
algorithm might catch that not have the
context that this is a u.s.
representative and this information is
already public so essentially this just
it highlights how insanely difficult it
is to monitor all of these posts and
then what is the volume like what are we
dealing with like how many posts do you
guys get a day hundreds of millions of
posts a day and how many human beings
are manually reviewing any of these
things I don't have that that number a
lot a lot thousands hundreds of
thousands how many employees you guys
have we have 4,000 employees around the
world that's it yeah we have 4,000
employees the reason that's crazy though
but stop and think about that 4,000
people that are monitoring hundreds of
millions of tweets and we we have a we
have a we have a small team who's
monitoring tweets and some of them are
employed by us some of them are
contractors throughout throughout the
world so 4,000 employees total 4,000
employees who are engineers who are
designers who are lawyers so the number
of people actually monitoring tweets is
probably less than a thousand well the
reason we don't give us specific okay
just we need to scale these dynamically
right if we see a particular event
within a within country we might hire a
hundred more people on contract to deal
with it
whereas they may not be full-time and
with us the entire tournament they they
have the ability to take down tweets
they have they have the so as we get
reports it goes into a queue and those
are ranked by severity and then we have
people who look at our rules and look at
the look at the tweets and look at the
behavior in the context around it and
they have the ability to go down that
enforcement spectrum the video talked
about one make people log in read why
it's a violation over tweet and delete
it to temporary suspensions and finally
a permanent suspension which is the
absolute last resort which we ultimately
do not want to do we want to make sure
that our rules are also guided towards
incentivizing more healthy conversation
and more more participation so so let me
ask you the rules you have are not based
in US law right US law doesn't recognize
restrictions on hate speech it's
considered free speech so if you wanna
stand in a street corner and yell the
craziest things in the world you're
allowed to on your platform Twitter
you're not allowed to so even in that
sense alone your rules do have an
ideology behind them I don't completely
disagree I think you know I don't want
harassment but the reason I bring this
up is getting into the discussion about
democratic health of a nation so I think
it's it can't be disputed at this point
that Twitter is extremely powerful in
influencing elections you know I'm
pretty sure you guys published recently
a bunch of tweets from foreign actors
that were trying to meddle in elections
so even you as a company recognize that
foreign entities are trying to
manipulate people using this platform so
I there's a few things I want to ask me
on this but if wouldn't it be important
then to just as at a certain point
Twitter becomes so powerful in
influencing elections and giving access
to even the president's tweets that you
should allow people to use the platform
based under the norms of US law First
Amendment free speech right to
expression on the platform this is
becoming too much of a it's becoming too
powerful and how our elections are
taking place so even if you are saying
well hate speech is our rule and a lot
of people agree with it if at any point
one person disagrees they're still an
American who has a right to this you
know to access to the public discourse
and you've essentially monopolized that
and not completely but for the most part
so isn't there some responsibility on
you to guarantee
at a certain extent less regulation
happen right like look if you recognize
foreign governments are manipulating our
elections then shouldn't you guarantee
the right to an American to access this
platform to be involved in the electoral
process I'm not sure I see the the the
time between those things but I will
address one of your points which is
we're not we're a platform that serves
the world so we're a global seventy-five
percent of the users of Twitter are
outside of the United States all right
right so we don't apply laws of just one
country when we're thinking about it we
think about how do you have a global
standard that can meet the threshold of
as many countries as possible because we
want all the people in the world to be
able to participate in conversations and
also meet elections like the Indian
election coming up as well right and I'm
understanding is you were also accused
of being biased against conservatives in
India recently there was a report on
that as well as you held up a sign that
said something offensive about the
Brahmin yeah so in that sense even in
other countries you're accused of the
same things that you're being accused of
by American conservatives I think that
the situations are very very different
and I don't think that that the
ideologies in play are the same at all
well so the reason I bring we clarify
that I I'm not sure what you're talking
about but we we did have our vice
president public policy testify in front
of Indian Parliament a couple of weeks
ago and he was they were really focused
on election integrity and safety and
abuse and harassment of women and
political figures and the likes so so my
concern I guess is I recognize you're a
globe you're a company that serves the
world but as an American I have a
concern that the democracy I live in the
Democratic Republic I'm sorry and the
democratic functions are healthy one of
the biggest threats is you know Russia
near Russia Iran China they're trying to
meddle in our elections using your
platform and it's effective so much so
that you've actually come out and
removed many people you know Covington
was apparently started by a count based
in Brazil you know the Covington scandal
where this fake news goes viral was
reported by CNN that was a it was a
dummy account they were trying to prop
it up and they were pushing out this out
of context information so they do this
they use your platform to do it you've
now got a platform that is so power
in our American discourse that foreign
governments are using it as weapons
against us and you've taken a stance
against the laws of United States I
don't mean like against like you're
breaking a lie mean you have rules that
go beyond the scope of the US which will
restrict American citizens from being
able to participate meanwhile foreign
actors are free to do so so long as they
play by your rules
so our elections are being threatened by
the fact that if there's an American
citizen who says I do not believe in
your misgendering policy and you banned
them that person has been removed from
public discourse on Twitter right but
they don't get banned for saying they
don't agree with it
sure specifically violating it by
targeting and in let's say in protest an
individual repeatedly says no I refuse
to use your pronouns in like Meghan
Murphy's case and she's Canadian so I
don't want to use her specifically the
point I'm trying to make is at a certain
level there are going to be American
citizens who have been removed from this
public discourse which has become so
absurdly powerful foreign governments
weaponize it because you have different
rules than the American country has so
just to be clear my understanding and
I'm not expert on all the platforms is
that foreign governments use multiple
multiple different ways to interfere in
elections it's not limited to our
platform nor is it limited to social
media but the president is on twitter
president is on a lot of different
platforms as is the White House
I think it's fair to point out the media
coverage of his Twitter account is
insane and they run news stories every
time you tweets and certainly undeniable
I'm just pointing out that there are a
number of different avenues for this and
individuals have choices and how they
use a platform yeah you know you have
other platforms but he uses Twitter and
exclusively and what I'm trying to bring
up is that if Twitter refuses to
acknowledge this problem you are facing
regulation I don't I don't know if you
care about that but at a certain point
which which problem if you're going to
restrict American citizens from
participating on a platform where even
the president speaks and and it's
essentially you have a private privately
owned public space if I could use an
analogy that would be most apt and
you've set rules that are not recognized
by the US in fact when it came to a
Supreme Court hearing they said hate
speech is not a violation it's actually
protected free speech so there's an
actual odds so there might be someone
who says I refuse to live by any other
means than what the Supreme Court is set
down that means I have a right to hate
speech you will ban them that means your
platform is so powerful
it's it's being used to manipulate
elections and you have rules that are
not recognized by the government to
remove American citizens from that
discourse so as a private platform
you've become too powerful to not be
regulated
if you refuse to allow people free
speech but I'm trying to pick apart the
connection I think so
yes we we do have an issue with foreign
entities and misinformation and and this
is a extremely complicated issue which
we're just beginning to understand and
grasp and and take action on I I don't
think that issue is solved purely by not
being more aggressive on something else
that is taking people off the platform
entirely as well which is abuse and
harassment like it it's a cost-benefit
analysis ultimately and our rules are
designed again and you know they don't
always manifest this way in the outcomes
but in terms of what we're trying to
drive is opportunity for every single
person to be able to speak freely on the
platform and that's that's absolutely
not true you would don't allow a lot of
aid speech so free speech is not on your
platform
I said speakable everyone they create
the opportunity for everyone to speak on
our service unless they've all right
it's hate speech right and then part of
that the recognition that we're taking
action on is that when some people
encounter particular conduct that we see
them wanting to remove themselves from
the platform completely which goes
against that principle of enabling
everyone to speak or giving people the
opportunity to speak so rules are
focused on the the opportunities
presented and we have particular
outcomes to make sure that those
opportunities are so let's let's
separate the first that the point I made
about foreign governments was just to
explain the the the power that your
platform holds and how can be weaponized
well separate that now when antifoam to
berkeley and bash as a guy over there
with a bike lock that is suppressing his
speech right that's a fact of physical
violence however when auntie fall links
hands and blocks a door so that no one
can go
to an event that is also legally allowed
right so what you're saying is that if
someone is engaging in behavior such as
going on Twitter and shouting someone
down relentlessly that's something
external to what happens in the world
under the US government I am allowed to
scream very close to you and not let you
speak in public but on Twitter you don't
allow that so there's a dramatic
difference between what Twitter thinks
is okay and what the US government
thinks is okay our democracy functions
and our Twitter functions the issue I'm
pointing out is that we know Twitter is
becoming extremely important in how our
public discourse is occurring how our
cultural culture is developing and who
even gets elected so if you have rules
that are based on a global policy that
means American citizens who are abiding
by all of the laws of our country are
being restricted from engaging in public
discourse because you've monopolized it
can I counter that though because these
foreign governments are restricted by
the same rules so if they violate those
same rules they will be they would be
removed so play within those rules they
can participate in the discourse even if
they are just trying to manipulate our
elections on the other hand if the
people that are on the platform play by
those rules
they can also counteract unless their
ideology goes in line with US law and is
legally allowed as opposed to what you
allow so foreign governments can can
absolutely keep making new accounts and
keep botting and keep manipulating they
can even post things that'll go viral
and then get banned and not care right
but a private American citizen can say
here's my opinion I refuse to back down
by series home you will ban him so we
can see that at a certain point you have
a lot you Twitter is slowly gaining in
my opinion too much control from your
personal ideology based on what you've
researched what you think is right over
American discourse if you if Twitter and
this again this is my opinion I'm not a
lawmaker but I would have to assume if
Twitter refuses to say in the United
States you are allowed to say what is
legally acceptable period then lawmakers
only choice will be to enforce
regulation on your company actually time
I spent quite a bit of time talking to
lawmakers as part of my role had a
public policy I spend a lot of time in
DC I want to say that Jack and I have
both spent a lot of time in DC and I
think from the perspective of lawmakers
they across this back
are also in favor of policing abuse and
harassment online and bullying online
those are things that people care about
because they affect their children and
if they affect their communities and
they affect individuals and so I don't
think that and as a private American
business we can have different standards
than what an American government-owned
corporation or American government would
have to institute those are two
different things
America but and I understand your point
about the influence and I'm not denying
that certainly Twitter is an influential
platform but like anything whether it's
the American law or the rules of Twitter
or the rules of Facebook or rules of any
platform there are rules and those rules
have to be followed so it is your choice
whether to follow those rules and to
continue to participate in a civic
dialogue and this choice to not do that
absolutely you've monopolized public
discourse to an extreme degree and and
you say my way or the highway we are
facing and we haven't monopolized that
there are many different avenues for
people to continue to have a voice there
are many different platforms that offer
that we are largely influential and I'm
not trying to take away from that and
we're a very important one you don't
need to be the most important it's just
that you are extremely important and
that's and it's a compliment twitter has
become extremely powerful but at a
certain point you should not have the
right to control what people are allowed
to say no private or I'm a social
liberal I think we should regulate you
guys because you are unelected officials
running your system the way you see fit
against the wishes of a Democratic
Republic and there are people who
disagree with you who are being excised
from public discourse because of your
ideology that terrifies me and we can
take it once that's just just so I
understand so are you suggesting that we
don't have any policies around abuse and
harassment on the platform I'm trying to
understand what it is you're saying
because I'm not I'm not sure I'm
following you so you don't think we
should have any rules about our abuse no
harassment so even that the threats that
you received that you know but you
mentioned a number of threats that you
received and you were quite frustrated
that we hadn't taken action on them you
think we shouldn't have roles that I'm
frustrated because of the hypocrisy I'll
say when I when I see own I see the flow
of one direction and then what I see are
Republican politicians who in my opinion
are just too ignorant to understand what
the hell's going on around
them and I see people burning signs that
say free speech I see you openly saying
we recognize the power of our platform
and we are not going to abide by
American norms
I see the manipulation of Twitter for in
violation of our elections
I see Democratic operatives in Alabama
waging a false flag campaign using fake
Russian accounts and this and the guy
who runs that company has not been
banned from your platform even after
it's been written by the New York Times
he was doing this so we know that not
only are people manipulating your
platform you have rules that remove
honest American citizens with bad
opinions who have a right to engage in
public discourse and it's like you
recognize it but you like having the
power I'm not quite sure get back to my
point so you believe that Twitter should
not have any rules about abuse and
harassment or any sort of hate speech on
the platform that that's your puzzle
that's that's that's a extremely
reductive I don't know that maybe maybe
too simplistic the point I'm trying to
make is but but you ain't you're trying
make your you're asking us to comply
with the US law that would criminalize
potential speech and put people in jail
for it and you're asking us to enforce
those that's traumatic well I mean if
you incite death you will yes a crime
you can go you can go to jail for that
so at the very least you could you like
when you have people on your platform
who committed crime you don't ban them I
say well that's really weird
and then you have people on your
platform who say a bad naughty word you
do ban them I say well that's really
weird
I mean I've seen people get banned for
tweeting an end to you I understand what
they're trying to do when they tweet
letters at you jack but they get
suspended for and they get a threat you
know like you can't let's looks like
about learning to code what do you mean
by that yeah so so so you know so there
are people who know that they can tweet
a single letter and the next person
knows what letter they need to tweet you
see I'm saying so you'll see you know
one user will say and the next user will
put an eye the next user really yes
and so they get suspended for doing so
and and these are these are the people
who are trying to push the buttons on
the rules right they get suspended for
that absolutely so because I think see
but here's the thing I think I think
your team understands what they're doing
however it get really dangerous
territory if someone someone
accidentally tweets an end and you
assume they're trying to engage in a
harassment campaign which is why I said
let's talk about learn to code what we
do we do look at coordination
of accounts or direct messages I don't
know about direct messages but under you
redirect messages we don't really we
don't read them unless someone reports a
direct message to us that they have
received until you read their direct
message that they send to you so if if
you have a direct message and someone
says something terrible and then like
you receive a death threat and you
report that to us thank you then we
would read it cuz you've reported it to
us do does anyone in the company have
access to direct messages other than
that only in the context again of
reviewing reports that they're not
accessible not to my knowledge I don't
know what you mean like we're not
accessible when tweeting them is it
possible that someone could go into
Tim's direct messages and just read his
direct messages I don't think so
so if Tim writes an N and I write an I
and Jamie writes a G can you go into our
direct messages and say hey let's [ __ ]
with Jack and we're gonna write this
stuff out and we're gonna do it and
let's let's see if they they ban us you
can't read that I don't think so I know
if that's the case how would you know if
there was a concerted effort in well I
think what he's saying is like if we if
we do see those train of replies and
that is that is coordination you know
what people are doing yes the question
is how do you prove it well I think
beyond the N you know the first person
with a letter you can't prove he did it
but everybody else you kind of can I
don't but I don't think we would well I
look like I can say this I've been sent
numerous screenshots from people
screenshots can be faked I recognize
that but I have seen people actually
tweet and then I've seen the tweet
follow right after one yes someone
tweeted at you
someone decently high-profile a big
youtuber tweeted an N at you and then
got like a 12-hour suspension but let's
talk about learn to code right and why
are people being suspended for tweeting
hashtag learn to code yep we did some
research on this yes we did some
research on this so there was a
situation and I guess about a month ago
or so where a number of journalists were
receiving a variety of tweets some
containing learned to code some
containing a bunch of other coded
language that was wishes of harm these
were thousands and thousands
tweets being directed at a handful of
journalists and we did some research and
what we found was a number of the
accounts that were engaging in this
behavior which is tweeting at the
journalists with this either learn to
code or things like day of the rope and
other coded language were actually ban
evasion accounts that means accounts
that had been previously suspended and
we also learned that there was a
targeted campaign being organized off
our platform to abuse and harass these
journalists that's not true see here's
the thing an activist who works for NBC
wrote that story and then lobbied you
you issued an official statement and
then even the editor-in-chief of the
Daily Caller got a suspension for
tweeting learned to code at the day at
the Daily Show so I have never talked to
anybody from NBC about this issue so I
know so they report it don't
misrepresent me they report it the
narrative goes far and wide amongst your
circles then all of a sudden you're
seeing high-profile conservatives
tweeting a joke getting suspensions so
again some of these tweets actually
contained death threats wishes of harm
other coded language that we've seen to
mean death to journalists so it wasn't
about just the learn to code it was
about the context that we were that's
just not true the editor-in-chief of The
Daily Caller was suspended for tweeting
nothing but hashtag learned to code sir
Tim can I can I finish what I'm saying
yeah so we were looking at the context
and what was happening is there were
journalists receiving hundreds of tweets
some had death threats
some had wishes of harm some just
learned to code and in that particular
context we made a decision we consider
this this type of behavior but dogpiling
which is when all of a sudden
individuals are getting tons and tons of
tweets at them they feel very abused or
harass on the mark we pause this guy
super confusing for people who don't
know the context the learned code thing
is in response to people saying that
people that are losing their jobs like
coal miners and truck drivers and things
like that could learn to code this was
it was almost like in jest initially or
if it wasn't in jest initially it was so
poorly thought out as a suggestion that
people started mocking it right correct
so those were the first stories that
came out were simply like Ken miners
learned to code no miners right and the
the hashtag learn to code is just a meme
it's not even necessarily a conservative
one that you will see more conservatives
using it was people are using it to mock
how stupid the idea of taking a person
who's I know educators in their 50s who
should learn some new form of vocation
and then someone says learn to code and
so then other people when they're losing
their job or when something's happening
people would write learn to code because
it's a mean well not even necessarily I
would I would characterize learn to code
as a meme that represents the elitism of
modern journalists and how they target
certain communities with disdain okay so
so to make that point there are people
who have been suspended for tweeting
something like I'm not too happy with
how you know BuzzFeed reported the story
hashtag learn to code right making
representation of these people are
snooty elites who live in ivory towers
but the but but again you know this is a
meme that has nothing to do with
harassment but you know it's some people
might be harassing somebody might tweet
it why would we expect to see even still
today I'm still getting messages from
people with screenshots saying I've been
suspended for using a hashtag and the
editor in chief of the Daily Caller
right he took he quote tweeted a video
from the Daily Show with hashtag learn
to code and he got a suspension for it
so why why learn to code why is that
alone so egregious and I don't think it
is so egregious so it's just something
that's stuck in an algorithm no it was a
again a specific set of issues that we
were seeing targeting a very specific
set of journalists and it wasn't just to
learn to code it was a couple of things
going on a lot of the accounts tweeting
learned to cone we're ban evaders which
means they'll curiously been suspended a
lot of the accounts had other language
in them are tweets out other language
like day of the brick day of the rope
oven-ready these are all coded meanings
for violence against people right and so
and they people who are receiving this
we're receiving hundreds of these and
what appeared to us to be a coordinated
harassment campaign and so we were
trying to understand the context of what
was going on and take action on them
because again I don't know Joe if you've
ever been the target of a dogpiling
event on Twitter but it is not
particularly fun when thousands of
people or hundreds of people are
tweeting at you and saying things and
that's can be viewed as a form of
Rassman it's not about the individual
tweet it is about the volume of things
that are being directed I don't
understand and so in that particular
case we made the judgment call and it is
a judgement call to take down the tweets
that were responding directly to these
journalists that were saying learn to
code even if they didn't have a wish of
harm specifically attached to them
because of what we viewed as coordinated
attempt to harass them and again like I
was saying some of the other signals and
coded language and we were worried that
learned to code was taking on a
different meaning I understand in that
particular context so but in and of
itself though it still seems like
there's alternative meanings to learn to
code it still could be used as Tim was
saying to mock a lip you know elite
snooty picture to Paris yes absolutely I
agree with you so it's really about the
context of what was happening in that
situation and all those other things I
think in a very different situation we
would not take action on that hmm okay
but does not seem like you're you're
throwing a blanket over a very small
issue and learn to code in itself is
very small the blanket has cast over
racism the blanket has cast over this
all the other horrible things that are
attached to it but the horrible things
that are attached toward the real issue
this learned the code thing is kind of a
legitimate protest in people saying that
these minors should learn to code that's
kind of preposterous the first articles
weren't mean it was just it the code
kind of identified you have these
journalists who are so far removed from
Middle America that they think you can
take a 50 year-old man who's never used
a computer before and put him in a row
no but the stories I think we're
legitimate yes but the the point more so
it was a meme the hashtag the idea of
learn to code condenses this idea and
it's easy to communicate especially when
you only have 22 characters that there
is a class of individual in this country
I think you mentioned on was a Sam
Harris that the left these left liberal
journalists only follow each other you
know in the in the run-up to the 2015
2016 elections yeah and so I mean I
still believe that to be true I've
worked in these offices it has changed
they've done the study again the
visualization and now there is a lot
more cross-pollination but we what we
saw is
folks who were recording on the left end
of the spectrum mainly followed folks on
the left and folks on the right followed
everyone right you were talking about
earlier that there's bubbles there's
there's bubbles and we've helped create
them yeah and and maintain them so so
here's what ends up happening and this
is one of the big problems that people
have with this story particularly
particularly you have a left-wing
activist who works for NBC News I'm not
accusing you of having read the article
he write he spends like a day lobbying
to Twitter saying guys you have to do
this you have to make these changes the
next day he writes a story saying that
4chan is organizing these these
harassment campaigns and death threats
and while 4chan was doing threads about
it you can't accuse fortune simply for
talking about because a reddit was
talking about it - as was Twitter so
then the next day he after he published
his article
now he's getting threats and then
Twitter issues a statement saying we
will take action and to make matters
worse when John Levine a writer for The
Wrap got a statement from one of your
spokespeople saying yes we are banning
people for saying learn to code a bunch
of journalists came out and then lied no
idea why saying this is not sure this is
fake news then a second statement was
published by Twitter saying it's part of
a harassment campaign and so then the
mainstream narrative becomes oh they're
only banning people who are part of a
harassment campaign but you literally
see legitimate high profile individuals
getting suspensions for joining in on a
joke oh they're there for sure probably
mistakes in there I don't think that any
of us are claiming that we got this
hundred percent right and probably our
team having a lack of context into
actually what's happening as well and
and we would fully admit we probably
were way too aggressive when we first
saw this as well so and made mistakes
I hope this clarifies then you have
situations like this where you can see
you know that this journalist I'm not
going to name him but he routinely has
very like left-wing I don't want to use
overtly esoteric words but the
intersectional dogmatic points of view
right so this is me so like
intersectional feminism is considered
like a small ideology it people refer to
these groups as the regressive left or
the identitarian left these are
basically people who hold views that a
person is judged based on the color of
their skin instead of the content of
their character so you have the
right-wing version which is like y'all
trite the left-wing version which is
like intersectional feminism
is-is-is how simply referred to so
you'll see people say things like you
know when they went typically when they
rag on white men or when they say like
white feminism these are these are
signals that they hold these particular
views and these views are becoming more
pervasive so what ends up happening is
you have a journalist who clearly holds
these views only wanna call him a
journalist he writes extremely biased
and out of context story twitter takes
action and responds seemingly in
response then we can look what happens
with Oliver Darcy at CNN he says you
know the people at CPAC are the
Conservatives are gullible eating red
meat from grifters among other things
disparaging comments about the right and
he's the one who's primarily advocating
for the removal of certain individuals
who you then remove and then when Kathy
Griffin calls for daxing that's fine
when this guy calls for the death of
these kids he gets it he gets a slap on
the wrist and and look I understand the
context matters but grains of sand to
make a heap and eventually you have all
of these stories piling up and people
are asking you why it only flows in one
direction click I got to be honest I'd
imagine that calling for the death three
times of any individuals abandon bull
offense even without a warning you just
get rid of them but it didn't happen
right we see we see these you know
people say men aren't women though and
they get a suspension we see people say
the editor-in-chief of the Daily Caller
may be the best example
hashtag learned to code quoting The
Daily Show and he gets a suspension
threatening death and inciting death is
a suspension - it feels like it's only
going in one direction yeah I think we
have a lot of work to do to explain more
clearly when we're taking action and why
and certainly looking into any mistakes
we may have made in this particular
situation so would you guys agree that
intact I think we can all agree this I
would hope you agree Tech tends to lean
left like tech companies any Facebook
Twitter Google I would be willing to bet
that a conservative running a social
network would not have a hate speech
policy I mean you look at gab and you
look at mines and mine's not even swing
right there not right-wing at all
they're just they just staunchly support
free speech right I don't think gap is
necessarily I don't think the owner is
necessarily right-wing either I don't
know much about him I think he's like a
libertarian I I don't want to I don't
want to yes by Safari either I don't
know enough yeah I know that there when
you read what they write they're just
staunchly committed to free speech but
they you know stop doxing
they will do things to stop targeted
harassment and daxing and things along
those lines sometimes slowly yeah yeah
but they want they just want an open
platform uh what my point is is that I
think a lot of people that are on the
right feel disenfranchised by these
platforms they use on a daily basis I
don't know what the percentage are the
percentages are in terms of the number
of people that are conservative they use
Twitter versus the number of people that
are liberal but I would imagine it's
probably pretty close isn't it
I don't know numbers I don't know
because we don't ask people but there
we'd have to we'd have to infer all that
okay so on what we're saying or because
so let's not even go there but then but
the the the people that run whether it's
Google or Twitter or Facebook any of
these platforms YouTube for sure
powerful leaning towards the left when
we all agree to that we don't ask our
employees but my guess is that many
employees the tech companies are
probably liberal it's really fascinating
but I also think yeah I mean you point
out all the companies you mentioned are
in exactly the same region as well yes
and do you know we do have the challenge
of some monocultural thinking yes well
but we and we you know I have said
publicly that you know yes we will have
more of a liberal bias within our
company so this to CNN right but that
doesn't mean that we put that in our
rules right but hold on McCallum because
what I'm getting at is that at some
point in time things have to get down to
a human being looking and reviewing it
cases and if you guys are so left-wing
in your your your staff and the area
that you live in and all these things
things are almost naturally going to
lean left if is that fair to say if we
were purely looking at the content but a
lot of this agent work is based on the
behaviors all the things that we've been
discussing in terms of the context of
the actual content itself except then
what the rules are except the
misgendering policy right so your rules
do reflect your your bubble right go to
middle and
go to middle America and go hang out at
conservative town they're not going to
agree with you your rules are based on
your bubble in San Francisco or whatever
city I'm from middle America I'm from
st. Louis Missouri and I I hear the
point I definitely hear the point in
terms of like us putting this rule forth
but we have to balance it with the fact
that people are being driven away from
our platform I hear you and they may not
disagree they may not agree with me on
that
my folks from Missouri but I think they
would see some valid argument in what
we're trying to do to again increase the
opportunity for as many people as
possible to talk that's that's it it's
not driving the edge that you're
speaking to where you stop what what
community is and isn't deserving of
protection our conservatives not
deserving of protection for their
opinions but I want to never being away
on individuals and increasing the
absolute number of people who have
opportunity to speak on the platform in
the first place so then do you need a
rule for a body dysphoria do you need a
rule for other kin right you see what
I'm asking you you you have a specific I
see what you're asking but like and and
this came from a call and research and
there are there's there's disagreement
as to whether this is the right outcome
or not and this is the right policy and
yes our bias does influence looking in
this direction and our bias does take
our biases influence us putting a rule
like this in place but is with the
understanding of creating as much
opportunity as possible for as many
people to speak based on the actual data
that we see right of people leaving the
platform because of experiences ahead
why did your research stop there it
hasn't stopped we are rules aren't set
and ain't something that just stops and
doesn't evolve we're going to constantly
question we're going to constantly get
feedback from people on every end of the
spectrum of any particular issue and
make changes accordingly and to your
credit and stop and to your credit I
really do appreciate that the fact that
you're very open about that you have
made mistakes and that you're continuing
to learn and grow and that your company
is reviewing these things and trying to
figure out which way to go and I think
we all need to pay attention to the fact
that this is a completely new road this
road did not exist 15 years ago there
was nothing there that is a tremendous
responsibility for any company any
of human beings to be in control of
public discourse on a scale
unprecedented in human history and
that's what we're dealing with here this
is not a small thing and I know people
that have been banned to them this is
this is a matter of ideology this is a
matter of this is a matter of that
there's a lot of debate being going on
here and this is one of the reasons why
I wanted to bring you on because Tim cuz
you know so much about so many of these
cases and so much because you are a
journalist and you're you're very aware
of the implications and all the problems
that have been that maybe have slipped
through my fingers
so I do want to make one thing really
clear though I have a tremendous amount
of respect and Trust for you and you say
you wanted to solve this problem simply
because you're sitting here right now
and these all these other companies
aren't right Jack you went on sam Harris
you were on get with GAD said and that
says to me a good-faith effort to try
and figure out how to do things right
like so as much as I'll apologize for
getting kind of angry and being
emotional because he was angry died look
we also haven't been great at explaining
our intent and there's that there's a
few things going on one as Joe indicated
centralized global policy as scale is
almost impossible and and we realizes
different services have different
answers this reddit has a community
based policy where each topic each
subreddit has its own policy and and you
know there's there's some benefit to
that so that's problem number one we
know that this very binary off or on
platform isn't right and it doesn't
scale and it ultimately goes against our
key initiative of wanting to promote
more healthier conversation I I just
don't think that's what you're doing I
and I hear you I hear you no but like so
we're not done we're not we're not done
we're not finished with our work and we
need to the reason I'm going on all
these podcasts and having these
conversations and ideally vigeous
getting out there more often as well
because we don't see enough friend here
enough for her we need to have these
conversations so we can learn we can we
can get the feedback and also pay
attention to where the technology is
going before the podcasts we talked a
little bit about and I talked about it
on this our previous podcast and also
Sam's
technology today is enabling content to
live forever in a way that was not
possible before you can say that
everything on the internet lives forever
but that's not it's generally not true
because any host or any connection can
take it down the blockchain changes all
that it can actually exist forever
permanently without anyone being able to
touch a government company individual
and that is a reality that we need to
pay attention to and really understand
our value and I believe a lot of our
value in in the future
not today again we have a tons of we
have a ton of work is to take a strong
stance of like we are going to be a
company that given this entire corpus of
conversation and content within the
world we're going to work to promote
healthy public conversation that's what
we want that's what we want to do and if
you disagree with it you should be able
to turn it off and you should be able to
access anything that you want as you
would with the internet but those are
technologies that are just in the
formative stages and presenting new
opportunities to companies like ours and
and there's a ton of challenges with
them and a ton of the things that we've
discussed over the past hour that it
doesn't solve and maybe exacerbates
especially around things like election
and parent interference and some of the
regulatory concerns at your brain so
there's a few issues right your
definition of what is or isn't healthy
right yes yes and and and we want that
to be public like we want that we're
going we have four indicators right now
that we're working on with an external
lab we want other labs too we want to
give it up open source make sure that
people can comment on it that people can
help us define it will use that
interpretation on our own algorithms and
then push it but that has to be open
that has to be transparent
are we there today absolutely not we're
not there I this course of action to me
looks like a Fahrenheit 451 future where
everything is so offensive everything
must be restricted I see that's the path
I see that you're on you want to have a
healthy conversation you want to
maximize the amount of people that means
you got to cut off all the tall grass
and level everything out so if you've
decided that this one rule needs to be
enforced because certain things are
offensive well but can I explain what
what health at least means to us in this
absolu yes so like
we talked a little bit about this on the
previous podcast but what we we have
four indicators that were trying to
define and try to understand if there's
actually something there one is shared
attention is a conversation generally
shared around the same objects or is it
disparate so like as we're having a
conversation the four of us are having
conversation are we all focused on the
same thing or is Joe on his phone which
you were earlier or like whatever is
going on because a more shared attention
will create will lead to healthier
conversation number two is shared
reality not whether something is factual
but are we sharing the same facts is the
earth round is the world flat so we not
men women or men yes we can tell what
facts are we sharing and what facts are
we not sharing what percentage of the
conversation so that's that's a second
indicator third is receptivity are the
participants receptive to debate and to
civility into expressing their opinion
and even if it is something that might
be hurtful are people receptive to at
least look at and be empathetic and look
at what's behind that we this is the one
we have the most measurement around
today we can determine and predict when
someone might walk away from a Twitter
conversation because they feel it's
toxic I just ignore them all basically
so and we see we see that in our data
right so you and there's some
conversations that you get into and you
and you you know persist and then the
finally is variety of perspective are we
are we actually seeing the full spectrum
of any topic that's being talked about
and and these are not meant to be taken
as individual parts but in unison how
they played together and we've written
these out
we haven't gotten far enough in actually
defining what they look like and what
they mean and we certainly haven't gone
good enough at understanding when we
deploy a solution like being able to
follow a hashtag does that impact
variety of perspective to the positive
does it impact shared reality to the
negative what not so this is how we're
thinking about it and as we think more
about that that influences our product
and influences our enforcement and
influences our policy as well what
describing sounds wildly different to
what Twitter is right so you have a goal
for where you want to get with those
those metrics so I what confuses me then
when you when we talk about someone like
Megan Murphy who sure she violated your
rules but in the context of a
conversation you know you recognize
people will sometimes get heated with
each other if you know how do you do is
a healthy conversation when no one is
being negative what if what if people
are yelling at each other and being mean
and insulting or misgendering them I I
think it's a question of what thresholds
you allow and the more control we can
give people to vary the spectrum on what
they want to see that feels right to me
I mean Joe and in your your Alex podcast
did exactly this thing you're hosting a
conversation you had both of your guests
who started talking over each other you
pause a conversation you said let's not
get combative someone said I'm not being
combative you said you're all talking
over each other and and there's a
dynamic that the conversation then
shifted to that got to some deeper
points right could have just said let
that happen and let it go and and that's
fine too it's it's it's up to who is
viewing and experiencing that
conversation and I agree with you it is
completely far off from where we are
today we've not only have we had to
address a lot of these issues that we're
talking about at this table but we've
also had to turn the company around from
a business standpoint we'd have we've
had to fix all of our infrastructure
that's over ten years old and we had to
go through two layoffs because the
company was too large so we have to
prioritize our efforts and I don't know
any other way to do this then be really
specific about our intentions and our
aspirations and and the intent and the
why behind our actions and not
everyone's going to agree with it in the
in the particular moment so I will I
want to I want to point this out before
I make my next statement though just
real quick it seems like the technology
is moving faster than the culture so I
do recognize you guys are in a rock and
a hard place how do you get to a point
where you can have that open source
crypto you know blockchain technology
that allows freed open speech at the
same time the technology exists Twitter
has been replicated
numerous times in different ways
Mastodon for instance what what's
disconcerting to me is I you know and
maybe you have research on this which is
why you've taken the decisions you have
but when you ban someone because they've
said you know bad opinions misgendering
well they're not going to go away
they're going to try and find anywhere
they can speak so what effectively
happens is you're taking all of these
people from from a wide range of the
most to use of prison analogy murderers
all the way to pot smokers and you put
them in the same room with each other
and you're saying you're not welcome
here well what happens when you take
someone who smokes pot and put them in
prison with a bunch of gangbangers and
murderers they fall into that so I
totally get the point I'm hyper aware of
our action sending more and more things
into the dark this is something that I
wanted to discuss this is really
important in this vein of thinking what
about roads to redemption what about
someone like Megan Murphy what about
someone anyone Alex Jones Milo is is it
can we find a path for people to get
back to the platform that for good or
for bad like it or not there is one
video platform that people give a [ __ ]
about and that's YouTube you get kicked
off a YouTube you're doomed and that's
just reality you can go Vimeo is
wonderful there's a lot of great video
platforms out there they have a [ __ ]
tiny fraction of the views at YouTube
dubs that's just reality the same thing
to be said for Twitter whether or not
other platforms exist is that's
inconsequential the vast majority of
people are on Twitter the vast majority
of people that are making you know posts
about the news and and breaking
information they do it on Twitter what
can be set up and have you guys given
consideration to some sort of a path to
redemption yeah there's there's
redemption and there's rehabilitation
okay you know we we haven't done a great
job at having a cohesive stance on
rehabilitation and redemption we haven't
in part so the the whole focus behind
the temporary suspensions is to at least
give people pause and think about why
they violated or why and how they
violated our particular
right signed up for when they came in
through our Terms of Service great
whether you agree with him or not like
this is the agreement that we have with
you no I'm just thinking this I'm sorry
to interrupt you but it would be kind of
hilarious if you guys had an option like
a mode of Twitter an angry mode like
[ __ ] I'm angry right now so I'm gonna
type some things and it says hey dude
why don't you just think about this
we're gonna hold it for you in the queue
and what you'll do that people do that
and people do that in their drafts but
and I'm sure they do I'm sure they do
but it would be funny if you had an
angry mode yeah but like you guys
noticed you guys are using a lot of
curse words and you're saying a lot of
bad things we're gonna put you in angry
mode so think about this so you have to
make several clicks if you want to post
this and there is research to suggest
that people expressing that actually
tends to minimize more violent physical
oh for sure everyone says that with
emails if you're if you've got if you're
in the middle of the night someone sends
you an email and you find salt and you
ready your type an email and then go to
sleep wake up in the morning like
someone say something nice you know
that's how I wind up interacting with
these people but what what do you think
can be done for people like let's say
Megan Murphy because she seems one of
the it's as easy to see her perspective
as any what do you think could be done
for her I think I think you're right I
think that I would love to get to a
point where we think of suspensions is
temporary and she's banned for life
right now that's the only option that
we've built into our rules but we have
every capability of changing that and
that's something that I want my team to
focus on is thinking about as Jack said
not just coming back after some time
bound period but also like what more can
and should we be doing within the
product itself early on to educate
people about the rules so one of the
things that we're working on is a very
very simplified version of the Twitter
rules that's two pages not 20 mm-hmm
I've made sure that my lawyers don't
write it and it's written and it's plain
English as we can we try to put examples
in there and like really taking the time
to educate people and I get people
aren't always going to agree with those
rules and we have to address that too
but at least simplifying it and
educating people so that they don't even
get to that stage but once they do
understanding that the
in different contexts in people's lives
different times they're gonna say and do
things they may not agree with and they
don't deserve to be permanently
suspended forever from a platform like
Twitter agree so how do you get to it so
we this is something that actually we
just had a meeting on this earlier this
week with our executive team and you
know identifying kind of some of the
principles by which we would want to
think about you know time bounding
suspension so it's work we have to do it
and we're gonna figure it out I'm not
gonna tell you it's coming out right
away but it's a it's on our roadmap it's
something we want to do why don't you
set up a jury system when someone
reports something instead of you having
to worry about it there would be no
accusation of bias if 100,000 users were
randomly selected to determine cuz scope
does this yeah and we've learned scope
does this you please explain that we are
so periscope has a content moderation
jury
so we flag based on the machine learning
algorithms and in some cases reports
particular replies we send them to a
small jury of folks to ask is this
against our firm service or is this
something that you believe should be in
the channel or not do you those I know
to be on the jury no it's it's random so
you're an engine and you decide whether
or not want to participate yep okay and
it's it's good it has some flaws that
has some some gaming aspects to it as
well but like we we do have a lot of
experiments that we're testing and like
we want to build confidence and like
it's actually driving outcomes that we
think are are useful and periscope is a
good playground for us across many
regards I think ultimately one of the
greater philosophical challenges is that
you are a massively powerful corporation
you have international investors I
believe there's a Saudi prince owns what
six percent of Twitter so when I is that
true I'm just gonna make sure it's well
we're we're a publicly traded
corporation buy stock but that doesn't
mean they have influence on day to day
well I think depending on which
political faction you ask they'll say
money is influence right so I'm not
gonna say that the Saudi prince who
invested in Twitter again I've only it's
been a while since I've read these
stories it's like showing up your
meetings and throwing his weight around
but as certainly not doing that but but
you know
for Mike to trust you right this guy's
through throwing over a billion dollars
I think into Twitter twitter has
influence on our elections foreign
governments foreign government actors
have stake and Twitter it worries me
then when you base your rules on your
personal decisions on an unelected group
of people you have such tremendous power
in this monopoly on public discourse
near monopoly like he was saying some
platforms as Twitter has no real
competition so I just have to hope and
trust you have the best interest at
heart but you at the end of the day it's
it's it's authoritarian no one chose you
to be in charge of this I understand you
mentioned you discovered Twitter but
Here I am looking at you know both of
you who have this tremendous power over
whether or not someone can get elected
you can choose to ban someone and tell
me all day and night you have a reason
for doing it I just have to trust you
that's terrifying there's no proof
there's no proof Alex Jones at any of
these things other than things he's
posted right I understand that that's
actually what I was on the phone with
Alex is texting me saying that he'd
never did anything to endanger any child
and that he was disputing what people
were saying about a video of a child
getting harmed and so do we just trust
an unelected I mean extreme extremely
wealthy individuals Saudi princes you
know it's a publicly traded company who
knows where the influence is coming from
your rules are blessing based on a
global policy and I'm sitting here
watching wow these people who are never
chosen in this position have too much
power over my my my my politics I think
that's why it's so important that we
take the time to build transparency into
what we're doing and that's part of what
we're trying to do is not just in being
here and talking to you guys but also
building it into the product itself I
think one of the things I've really
loved about a new product launch what
we've done is to disable any sort of
ranking in the home timeline if you want
and you don't have to see our algorithms
that play anymore these are the kinds of
things that we're thinking about how do
we give power back to the people using
our service so that they can see what
they want to see and they can
participate the way they want to
participate and this is a long-term and
I get then we're not there yet
but this is how we're thinking about it
and you can imagine where that goes I
mean in just one switch and turning all
the algorithms off what what does that
do what does that look like so these are
the conversations that we're having in
the company whether they be good ideas
or bad ideas we we haven't determined
that just yet but we we definitely look
I def
understand the mistrust that people have
in our company in myself in the
corporate structure in all the variables
that are associated with it including
who chooses to buy on the public market
who chooses not to I I get all of it and
I grew up on the Internet
I'm a believer in the Internet
principles and I want to do everything
in my power to make sure that we are
consistent with those ideals at the same
time I want to make sure that every
single person and do everything in my
power has the opportunity to participate
let me ask you a question then for your
policy as it pertains to say Saudi
Arabia right do you enforce the same
hate speech rules on Saudi Arabia our
rules are global we enforce them against
everyone so even in countries where it's
criminal to be LGBT you will still ban
someone for for saying something
disparaging to or some attach that to
that effect like let's say Saudi Arabia
send someone's to it to death for I
don't want to call us how your be a
specific let's call it Iran because I
believe that's the the big focus right
now with Trump administration Iran it's
my understanding it's still punishable
by death I could be wrong but it is
criminal
if someone then directly targets one of
these individuals will you ban them I
mean do you guys function n Iran because
I think we're blocked in Iran yeah so I
figured but there but there are some
countries where for instance Michelle
Malkin recently got really angry because
she received notice that she violated
blasphemy laws in Pakistan right so you
do follow some laws in some countries
but it's not a viola question I'm asking
is when Pakistan it's very clearly a
different culture they don't agree with
your rules we do have a per country
takedown meaning that content might be
non visible within that country but
visible throughout the rest of the world
but so just to add on to what Jack
saying we actually are very very
transparent about this so we publish a
transparency report every six months the
details every single request that we get
from every government around the world
and the content that they ask us to
remove and we post that to an
independent third party site so you
could go right now and look and see
every single request that comes from the
Pakistani government and what content
they're trying to remove from Pakistan
and I've seen a lot of conservatives get
angry about this and it's kind of
confusing confusing I'm like that's a
really good thing I would want to know
if Pakistan wanted to kill me where the
anger
blasphemy laws posting pictures of
Muhammad so it's a crime are they angry
about our transparency reporter there's
a perception that you sending that
notice is like a threat against them for
violating blasphemy laws whereas it's
very clearly just letting you know
government has taken action against you
which it's saying that the government
has restricted access to that content in
that country and the reason we tell
users are tell people that that's
happened is because a lot of them may
want to file their own suit against the
government or a lot of them may be in
danger if they happen to be under that
particular government's jurisdiction and
they may want to take action to protect
themselves if they know that the
government is looking at the content in
their accounts so we don't always know
we don't we send the notice to everybody
we don't always know where you are or
what country you live in and so we just
send that notice as like to try to be as
transparent as possible the main point I
was trying to get to is your policies
support a community but there may be
laws in a certain country that does not
support that community finds it criminal
right so your actions are now directly
opposed to the culture of another of the
country I guess the point trying to make
is that if you enforce your values which
are you know perceivably not even the
majority of this country if you're you
know consider yourself some more liberal
leaning and you're half of the United
States but you're enforcing those rules
on the rest of the world that use the
service it's sort of forcing other
cultures to adhere to yours so a lot of
a lot of our rules are based in more the
UN declaration doesn't just purely us
doesn't the UN declaration guarantee the
right of all people through any medium
to express their opinion it does and it
also has can it also has conditions
around particular speech inciting
violence and some of the some of the
aspects that we speak to as well and it
protects certain categories whether it's
religion race gender sexual orientation
those are also also protected under the
UN covenant to protect human rights ooh
pause talk about don't worry I don't
want to just just saying I've got a
bunch of other things that you know cuz
you're the thing there's a bunch of
other issues having to do with bias and
censorship and I feel like we've kind of
like beaten that horse relentlessly but
I
that horse is good to beat it's also
good to address why the horse is beaten
and why why it exists in the first place
and I I really wanted to say this again
I really appreciate the fact that you
guys are so open and that you're willing
to come on here and talk about this
because you don't have to this is your
decision and especially you Jack after
we had that first conversation and the
the blowback was so hard you want it to
come and clarify this and I think this
is so important to give people of a true
understanding of what your intentions
are versus what perceptions are then and
thank you for hosting us again and um
look I I think it's also important that
the company is not just me we have
people in the company who are really
good at this and are making some really
tough decisions and having tough
conversations and and getting pushed
back and getting feedback and they have
the best intentions I don't so what so
let's I'll get back into the meat of
things to get to beating the dead horse
yeah I don't know if you have any data
on why Jacob Wall was recently banned do
you have that I believe who was Jacob
wall he's uh I don't know described me
as a conservative personality but he's
very very controversial for like fake
news or something I don't know too much
about him so I don't want to accuse him
of things I don't know who he is but he
was he was in something where he tried
accusing Moeller of like sexual assaults
and it turned out to be like just
completely fake ridiculous this is a
gentleman that was in the USA Today
article where he admitted that he was
going to he had used tactics in the past
to influence the election and he will
continue to do so using all of his
channels yes and when we saw that report
our team looked at his account we
noticed there were multiple accounts
tied to his account so fake accounts
that he had created that were discussing
political issues and pretending to be
other people we would have phone numbers
linking accounts together or email
addresses in some cases IP addresses
other types of metadata that are
associated with accounts so we can link
those accounts together and how multiple
accounts in and of itself is not a
violation of our rules because some
people have their
work account the personal account it's
when you're deliberately pretending to
be someone else and manipulating a
conversation about a political issue and
those are exactly the types of things
that we saw the Russians do for example
in the 2016 election so it was that
playbook and that type of activity that
we saw about Jacob Wall and that's why
his accounts were suspended did you
investigate Jonathan Morgan I don't know
who that is why that's that's the
important question why I I don't I don't
know who that is but that's that's nice
it might be that someone at Twitter
investigated him I personally don't know
who that so one of one of the issues
that I think is really important to get
to is you should know who he is he's
more important than Jacob Wallace but
for some reason you know about this
conservative guy and not the Democrat
who helped meddle in the Alabama
election well so Jonathan
of course it does need a sheer volume
that they have to pay attention to right
right right but it's it's about grains
of sand making a heap in the flow of a
direction where we can see Jacob Wall
has said he's done this so you're like
we're gonna investigate we ban him it
was recently reported and covered by
numerous outlets that a group called new
knowledge was meddling in the Alabama
election by creating fake Russian
accounts to manipulate national media
into believing that Roy Moore was
propped up by the Russians Facebook
banned him as well as for their people
but Twitter didn't did ban the accounts
that were engaged in the behavior I do
remember that I do remember sending mr.
vigilante
that's worse though so you didn't ban
the guy doing it but you banned the
people like so in the case of Jacob wall
we were able to directly attribute
through email addresses and phone
numbers his direct connection to the
accounts that were created to manipulate
the election if we're not able to tie
that direct connection on our platform
or law enforcement doesn't give us
information to tie attribution we won't
take action and it's not because of
political ideology it's because we want
to be damn sure before we take action on
it so someone could use a VPN perhaps
and maybe additional email accounts and
they could game the system in that way
there are certainly sophisticated ways
that people can can do things to mask
who they are and what accounts that
they're traditionally and just the
internal conversation to just to provide
more light into what happens like I got
a I got a email or text from gujja one
morning and said we are going to
permanently suspend this particular
account
it's not a you know what do you think
it's we are going to do this and I then
have an opportunity at to ask questions
I asked a question why she gave me a
link back to the document of all the
findings in USA Today we took the action
I was on Twitter a bunch of people
pointed me at this particular case since
some of those tweets to her what's going
on so that's well just in the background
wouldn't you just terminate anybody
associated with the company that was
doing this I mean keep in mind too at
the time when this campaign was
happening is what this is what bases he
had he admitted to engaging in the
operation in a quote to New York Times
and you banned the accounts associated
with it so if you know he's the one
running the company wouldn't you be like
okay you're gone do you want us to take
every single newspaper accounts
attribution because what we were able to
do in the Jacob Wall situation was
actually tie those accounts in our own
systems right that he we have to control
the routes not just take the word of a
newspaper you can never say you said you
banned his accounts yes and you know
from his own statement and from his
tweets that he was the run running or
running the company Jacob wall no no
Jonathan Morgan oh sorry I'm getting
confused about sober so Jacob wall it's
announced in the USA Today he says I'm
doing this and you're like okay we can
look at how we can see if we get rid of
them with with new knowledge you said
you did take those counts down I believe
we were able to take down a certain
cluster of accounts that we saw engaging
in the behavior but we won't weren't
necessarily able to tie it back to one
person controlling those even if they
say they did it do you this is where I
get back like we like to have some sort
of attribution that's direct that we can
see would we just take the any newspaper
or any article at face value and just
action them that's good you have to
contact him and get some sort of a
statement from him in order to take down
his account obviously I don't think he
would admit to manipulating Twitter
after the fact that he communicated with
a newspaper write to clarify what they
said what they claimed to the New York
Times was that was a false flag near
time said they reviewed internal
documents that showed they admitted it
was a false flag operation the guy who
runs the company said oh his company
does this he wasn't aware necessarily
but it was an experiment so he
he's given kind of in my opinion
duplicitous like you know not
straightforward but at the time of this
campaign which he claims to know about
he tweeted that it was real so during
the Roy Moore campaign he tweets wow
look at the Russians then it comes out
later his company's the one that did it
so you're kind of like oh so this guy
was propping up his own fake news right
then when they get busted he goes oh no
it's just my company doing an experiment
but you tweeted it with spearmint you
use your verified Twitter account to
push the fake narrative your company was
pumping on this platform and so so the
point I want to make I guess is it
sounds like we need to take a closer
look at this one
bana bring back morgan well well- morphe
Megan Murphy
sorry Morgan Murphy is a friend of mine
too
sorry so this is I haven't read the
story it's been like two months since
the story broke so I could have my you
know I don't want to I don't want to get
sued and have my facts wrong but the
reason I bring us up was not to accuse
you of wrongdoing was to point out that
I don't I don't think that the people
who work at Twitter are twirling their
mustaches laughing you know pressing the
band button whenever they see a
conservative I think it's just there's a
bias that's unintentional that flows in
one direction so you see the news about
Jacob wall and I think there's a reason
for it too there's a couple reasons for
one yours your staff is likely more
you've mentioned more likely to lean
left and look at certain sources so
you're going to hear about more things
more often and take action on those
things as opposed to the other side of
the coin but but we have to consider
like where the actions are taking place
I'm speaking more broadly to the 4,000
people that we have as a company versus
nono deliberateness that we have on
bridges team I just mean when we when we
look at a company wide average of all of
your employees and the direction they
lean versus the new sources they're
willing to read you're going to see a
flow in one direction whether it's
intentional or not and so I think the
challenge is we don't generally rely on
new sources to find interpolation of our
platform but we're looking at what we're
seeing the signals we can see and once
in a while we will get tipped off to
something but like for the most part
when we're looking at manipulation it's
not like the New York Times can tell us
like what's going on on the platform
we're the ones that have the metadata
about counts we're the ones that can see
pattern to behavior about scale but it's
at a point I do one name and I didn't
know another name and it was because
video said you know we're primarily
banning this account and
yes we we didn't have the same sort of
findings in the other particular account
which I got feedback on passed to her
and we don't I think but to be clear the
team had taken action on those stuff
months ago when it actually it happened
yeah I think you know a lot of what
people assume is mal-intent is sometimes
fake news you know I think one of my
biggest criticisms in terms of what's
going on our culture is the news system
is like you pointed out although it's
changed left-wing journalists only
follow themselves I
that's my experience I've learned for
these companies and so they repeat these
same narratives they don't get out of
their bubble even today they're still in
a bubble and they're not seeing what's
happening outside of it and then what
happens is you know we according to data
I think this is from pew most new
journalism jobs are in blue districts so
you've got people who only hear the same
thing they only cover the same stories
so if you know we hear all about Jesse
Smollett we hear about how the stories
that goes wild but there's like 800
instances of Trump supporters wearing
megawhatts getting beaten you know
throughout the past couple years we had
a guy show up to a school in Eugene
Oregon with a gun and fire two rounds at
a cop wearing a smash the patriarchy and
chill shirt and those stories don't make
the headlines so it's you know when the
journalists are inherently in a bubble
the information you're going to get is a
big company who follows these news
organizations is going to be inherently
you know one-sided as well and then the
only action you're gonna be able to take
is what you know you can't ban someone
if you don't know they're doing it here
yeah I think their biggest issue and the
thing that I I want to fix the most is
the fact that we create and sustain and
maintain these echo chambers yeah well
you you're rolling out that new feature
that allows you to hide replies right
we're testing we're experimenting with
an ability to enable people to have more
control as you would expect a host over
the conversation and like Facebook
allows that yeah but I don't think they
have the level of transparency that we
want to put into it so we actually want
to show whether a comment was moderated
and then actually allow people to see
those comments so both showing the
action that this person moderated a
particular comment and then you can
actually see the comment so if it's one
one click one click over one tap over
that's how we're thinking about it it
might change in the future but we week
do this without a level of transparency
because we minimize something Vidya
spoke to earlier which is speaking truth
to power holding people to account even
things like the the fire festival where
you know you have these organizers who
were deleting every single comment
moderating every single comment that
called this thing of fraud and don't go
here we can't we can't we can't reliably
and and we like just from a
responsibility standpoint ever create a
feature that enables more of that to
happen and that's how we're thinking
about even features like this I'm going
to jump right off into a different train
cart here has law enforcement ever asked
you to keep certain people on the
platform even after they violated your
rules so then this you know to the to
the next question pertaining to bias you
have the issue of an tyfa versus the
proud boys and patriot prayer and
twitter permanently excised anyone
associated with a proud boys anti-fog
accounts who have broken the rules
repeatedly branded known cells that have
been involved in vents also active is
there a reason well with the proud boys
what we were able to do was actually
look at documentation and announcements
that you know the leaders of that
organization had made and their use of
violence in the real world so that was
warrior focused on and subsequent to our
decision i believe the FBI also
designated that's not true it's not true
that's not true no okay no it's not true
yet you know so proud boys started out
as a joke gavin McGinnis Anthony ku Mia
who was a part of Opie and Anthony now
is his own show
told me about it happened on his show
because there was a guy that was on the
show and they made a joke about starting
a gang based on him because he was a
very effeminate guy and they would call
him the proud boys and they went into
detail about how this thing became from
a joke and saying that you could join
the proud boys and everyone was you know
it was like being silly
to people joining it and then it
becoming this thing to fight an Tifa and
then becoming infested with white
nationalists and becoming well think
well in in in many ways at hell it was
but it's been documented how it started
and what it was and misrepresented
as to what why was started IIIi think
there's some things that should be
clarified about them but Gavin has made
a bunch of statements that cross the
line he can yes he claims to be joking
and so that's that's what he did on my
podcast he was talking to me about an
Tifa that when antipholus blocking
people like ben shapiro speeches and
things along those lines and stopping
conservatives for speaking you should
just just punch him in the face we're
gonna have to start kicking people's
asses sounds like this is irresponsible
of a foolish and short-sighted and just
a dumb way to talk so then you have the
anti faux groups that are engaging in
the same thing we've you know that the
famous bike lock basher incident where a
guy showed up hit seven he hit seven
people over there with a bike lock they
subsequently released a name i'm gonna
leave that out for the time being you
have other groups like by any means many
means necessary you have in portland for
instance there are specific branded
factions there's the the tweet i
mentioned earlier where they doxed ice
agents and they said do whatever
inspires you this information and I mean
you're tagged in a million times I know
you probably can't see it but you can
actually see that some of the tweets and
the threat are removed but the main
tweet itself from an anti-fascist
account linking to a website straight up
saying like here's the private home
details phone number addresses of these
law enforcement officers has not removed
since September so here's what you end
up seeing is again the point I think one
of the big problems in this country is
the media because it was reported that
the FBI designated probably was an
extremist group but it was a
misinterpretation based a sheriff wrote
a draft saying with you know the FBI
considers them to be extremists the
media then reported hearsay from the
sheriff and the FBI came out said no no
no we never meant to do that that's not
true
we were just concerned about violence so
the proud boys all get purged and again
I think you know Gavin's a different
story right if you want to go after the
individuals who are associating with
that group versus the guy who goes on
this show and says rageous things and
goes on Joe's show well then you have an
tyfa branded cells like i'm what i mean
by that is they have specific names they
sell merchandise and they're the ones
showing up throwing mortar shells into
crowds they're the ones showing up with
crowbars and bats and whacking people I
was in Boston and there was a rally
where conservatives were planning on
putting on a rally was literally just
like libertarians and conservatives
anti-fur shows up with crowbars bats in
balaclavas with weapons
threatening them and so I have to wonder
if you know these people are allowed to
organize in your platform are you
concerned about that why aren't they
being banned when they violate the rules
yeah absolutely concerned about that has
the FBI designated them it's a domestic
turn yes I'm sorry Homeland Security in
New Jersey has listed them under
domestic terrorism okay so so here that
I understand is a conundrum in that the
general concept of anti-fascism is a
loose term that means you oppose fascism
room but an tyfa is now they have a flag
they've had a flag since the Soviet you
know so Nazi Germany in the Soviet era
and they've brought it back there are
specific groups that I'm not going to
mention by name that have specific names
and they sell merchandise they've
appeared in various news outlets they've
expressed their desire to use violence
to suppress speech there was is it a
centralized organization the same way
that I I hear you on probably's but like
where they have like tenants that are
written out and there's a leader and
like it's not the same but there are
specific branded cells that's why I
bring them up specifically I realize you
know someone showing up to a rally
wearing a black hoodie and sunglasses
who even a ban but there are groups that
that organize specifically call for
violence they push the line as close as
lightly as possible they advocate
sabotage and things like this and you
know when the proud boys go out and get
into fights they're not getting in
fights of themselves they're you know so
and I should point out that they decided
to call for violence based on and Tifa
calling for violence yeah based on
antifa
actually actively committing violence
against conservative people that were
there to see different people well it
partly started because in Berkeley there
was a trump rally so actually after Milo
got chased out of the Berkeley they were
there was a hundred thousand dollars in
damages I mean there's a video of some
guy in all black cracking someone on the
back was on the ground looking what
their unconscious so these conservatives
see this and they decide to hold a rally
saying we won't back down they hold a
rally in Berkeley and then anti-fur
shows up again I understand you can't
figure out who these people are for the
most part they're decentralized but then
this incites an escalation you then get
the rise of the base to stick man they
called it this a guy shows up in armor
with a stick and he starts swinging back
and now you have two factions forming so
while I recognize it's much easier to
ban a top-down group there are you know
the difference I guess is while you look
at the proud ways it's straight top-down
vertical you
look at an taifa and there's different
cells of varying size and their
different accounts so I have to to like
I guess the argument I could make is if
you're gonna ban the proud boys by all
means under your justification but if
you look at a specific channel that's
got twenty thousand followers that
cheers them on right these are people
who throw mortar shells into crowds
isn't that advocating for you know
terrorism and citement of violence yeah
absolutely
so I guess the question is how come they
don't get removed well in the past when
we've looked at an TiVo we it's we ran
into this decentralization issue which
is we weren't able to find the same type
of information that we were able to find
about Bravo's which was a centralized
leadership based documentation of what
they stand for but absolutely I mean
it's something we'll continue to look
into and to the extent that they were
using Twitter to organize any sort of
offline violence that's completely
prohibited under our rules and we would
absolutely take action but I ask you why
Gavin was banned it was there a specific
thing that he did or was it as
association with the proud boys
association with you know he's abandoned
that he's not only that he's
disassociated himself with it and said
that it completely got out of hand he
doesn't wanna have anything to do with
it yeah and I think this is a great
again test case for how we think about
getting people back on the platform if
he's an interesting case because he's a
really a provocateur and he fancies
himself you know sort of a punk rocker
and he just he likes stirring [ __ ] I
mean when he came on my show last time
he was on he was dressed up like Michael
Douglas and falling down you know he did
it on purpose he brought a briefcase and
everything I'm like what are you doing
it's like I'm Michael Douglas I'm
falling down like he's he's showman in
many ways and he did not mean for this
to go the way it went he thought it
would be this sort of innocent fun thing
to be a part of and then other people
got involved in it and when people call
for violence the problem is they think
that you know you're gonna just hit
people and it's gonna solve a problem it
just creates a much more much more
comprehensive problem it's important to
point out Gavin said has had many like
he said things way worse thing than Alex
Jones ever didn't turn whether whether
you want to say it's a joke or not he
said things like you know choke on punch
only uh-huh yep but but I guess was the
primary reason for
getting rid of them was what you thought
that the FBI had designated them
extremist group no cuz we did it
medicine months in advance okay yeah I
was just so he just it was just his
association with the proud boys I don't
recall and I would have to go back and I
don't want to misstate things I don't
want them all whether those statements
that you're referring to you if Gavin's
were on Twitter so they weren't there's
another you know when it comes to the
weaponization of rules against like
Gavin isn't creating a compilation of
things he's ever said out of context and
then sending them around get himself
banned other people are doing that to
him activists who don't like him and
it's effective in fact I would actually
like to point out there's one particular
user who has repeatedly made fake videos
attacking one of your other high-profile
conservatives so much so that he said to
file police reports harassment
complaints and it just doesn't stop you
know so I guess I'll ask this to this
regard if someone repeatedly makes
videos of you out of context fake audio
accusing you of doing things you've
never done at what point is that banner
bull yeah and if it's targeted
harassment and we can establish it it's
just a really hard thing with us
determining whether something is fake or
not well when things are out of context
you still have video the person saying
that I agree that it's out of contest
it's disingenuous but it's still the
person saying it and you're making a
compilation of some pre-existing audio
or video so I think in this instance of
Gavin like one of the things he said was
like a call to violence but he was
talking about okay it was in the context
of talking about a dog and being scolded
yeah so he was like hit him just hit him
and then it's like it turns out he's
talking about a dog like running
something wrong when they take that they
snip it and then it goes viral and
anyone starts flagging saying you gotta
banned this guy so again I understand
you like you know but I guess the issue
is if people keep doing that to destroy
someone's life so so I think there's a
there's a bigger Kurdish question I
think both of you could probably had
some important light on to outside of
Twitter this weaponization of content
from platforms is being used to get
people banned from their banking
accounts you know there get there we can
talk about patreon for instance and
again I'm not this is this may just be
something you could chime in on patreon
banned man named Carl Benjamin also
known as Sargon of Akkad he's also
banned from Twitter and it was was you
know why he got banned from Twitter I
can see that's an inch
I do have some some of the details here
do you want me to read you please okay
um looks like it's gonna be gross it's
not stuff that I love saying but I will
say it what Jack said he doesn't like
cursing either let's see I curse more
than he does so I guess I should say it
first strike [ __ ] white people kill
almond eyes system none of the above
qualify as hate speech what kid was that
I don't have the dates I'm sorry but
he's he's a white guy I mean obviously
he's joking around they're like white
people it also sounds to make a point
about your holes and how you enforce
them not actually possibly well which is
also exactly why you get kicked off a
patreon he was exactly yeah well I know
he also posted a photo of interracial
gay porn at some white nationalist to
make them angry yes yeah he's funny way
he's funny somebody I can understand how
posting that photo is an egregious
violation of the rules whether whether
or not he was trying to insult some
people that's a very good point and I
wanted to bring that up is porn a
violation of the rules porn generally no
good really good for you oh and why
would ends in my feet all the time I
follow a couple naughty girls and
occasionally they post pictures of
themselves engaging in intercourse I'm
like yikes
so then what else were the other strikes
for Sargon um let's see there was the
use of a Jewish slur how do you use it
to a person you trader remainer white
genocide supporting is llama file Jewish
slur lover that should keep you going
hashtag Hitler was right but but these
are the general opinions these are these
are targeted at somebody that that
sounds like he's being slaughtered like
he's making a joke yeah in context it
sounds like the other one like in
context what he's saying particularly
the fact that he's a white guy that
doesn't sound like a racial slur at all
I mean he's saying [ __ ] white people his
wife in context again these are tied
together right I always knew that person
was not
trusted that [ __ ] Jewish slur oh so
there's a bunch of very specific person
targeting very trying to be very precise
saying about a specific Jewish person I
don't know the race of this person I'm
sorry and this is not okay but this is
not it is not parody this is not joking
around
we didn't view it that way I'm just I'm
not trying to like read all this I'm
just telling you what they were like it
I knew he had done things that were like
egregious violations of the rules cuz
you know playing simple I didn't bring
him up to you know go through and try
and figure out a feat but that it does
sound like at least the first one was
meant to be drunk of here so potentially
but there are a bunch of others if you
want to hear I'm more than sure he
burrows is again targeted this is how I
know one day that I'll be throwing you
from a helicopter you're the same kind
of malignant cancer don't forget it so
there's just it's not one thing or two
things or three things this is like a
bunch of them the engines of grandeur
imagine think you gonna throw someone
from a well he doesn't believe you in
that but admittedly and I so so he's on
YouTube by the name of Sargon of Akkad
he's a big account and I've criticized
him for being overly mean in the past
and I think it's exactly it's angry but
but he is a very different now and I
guess the reason I brought him up was
he's very different now how so well a
lot of the content he makes is much
calmer he's less likely to insult
someone directly he makes probably
recognizing that he's on his last straw
oh definitely kicked off of Twitter he's
on YouTube he's probably gonna mind his
P's and Q's
oh but so the reason I brought him up
again but move on was that activists
found a live stream from eight months
ago again I totally forgot why I was
bring us up because we've moved so far
away from when we were but they pulled
this clip from an hour and a half or
whatever into a two-hour live stream on
a small channel that only had two
thousand views sent to patreon and then
patreon said yep that's a violation and
banned him outright without warning
which I understand is different from
what you guys do you do suspensions
first
but I guess the reason I was bringing up
was to talk about a few things
why blocking isn't enough why muting
isn't enough and if you think that it's
driving people off the platform people
post my tweets on Reddit I block them
they use a dummy account load up my
tweet pose it to Reddit and then spam me
on reddit so you know blocking and even
leaving Twitter would never do anything
short of me shutting up
there's nothing you can do to protect me
or anyone else look I mean these are
exactly the conversations we're having
one the reason why I don't think
blocking and reading are enough is one I
don't think we've made me powerful
enough it's spread all over the surface
you you can use it and then you got to
go find where you actually mean these
people are another profile page and
that's just it's not a it's a disaster
it just doesn't work in the same way
that it should work in the same way that
follow works it's just the inverse of
that I noticed that now I get a
notification that says you can't see
this tweet because you meted this person
right before I would just see a weird
reply and be like oh it's one of those
exactly you know so there's also all
this infrastructure that we have to fix
in order to like pass those through in
terms of what action you took or what
actions someone else took to be
transparent about what's happening on
the network and the second the second
thing that block is really interesting I
think it's a my own view is its wholly
unsatisfying because what you're doing
is you're blocking someone they get
notification that you've blocked them
which may involve them them even more
which causes you know others around and
ramifications from from the network but
also that person can log out to Twitter
and then look at your tweets just on the
public web because we're Republic so
exactly it doesn't feel as as rigorous
and as durable something like making me
much stronger but I guess the challenge
is no matter what rule you put in place
people are going to harass you if you're
if you're engaging in public discourse
you know if I go out in the street and
and yell out my opinion somebody could
get in my face if I get off Twitter cuz
I'm sickened I mean look you know I'm
sure you get a way worse than I do
especially is you know the high profile
probably came in right now yeah totally
owe me to God but so the only thing I
can do is look we're not on Twitter
right now we're on Joe Rogan's podcast
and they're still going to target you on
Twitter they're still gonna I guarantee
we're all over edit the the left is
probably railing on me the rights
railing on you guys so it's it's it
seems like even if you try everything in
your power to make Twitter healthier and
better it's not going to change anything
no I'm sure about that
I'm not sure about that because one of
the things that I do think is that just
I'm not in favor of a lot of this heavy
handed banning and a lot of the things
that have been going on particularly
like a case like the Megan Murphy case
but what I think that we are doing is
we're we're exploring the idea of civil
discourse where we're trying to figure
out what's acceptable and what's not
acceptable and you're communicating
about this on a very large scale and
it's putting that out there and then
people are discussing it whether they
agree or disagree whether they
vehemently defend you or or hate you
they're discussing this and this is I
think this is how these things change
and they change over long periods of
time think about words that were
commonplace just a few years ago that
you literally can't say anymore right
you know I mean there's so many of them
that we're extremely commonplace not
even thought to be offensive ten years
ago that now you can get banned off
aplausos for but that's a good point to
argue against banning people and to
cease enforcing hate speech rules yeah I
did with that as well I think it's both
things let me let me let me tell you
something important I was in the UK at
an event for a man named count dink EULA
who I don't know if you've heard of sure
yeah yeah Thank You Liz the guy who got
charged and convicted of making a joke
where had his pug do a Nazi salute but I
was there and I was arguing that a
certain white nationalist had used
racial slurs on YouTube he has I don't
want to name him and some guy in the UK
said that's not true he's never done
that and I said you're crazy let me pull
it up unfortunately I don't know why but
when I did the Google search nothing
came up what I did notice was at the
bottom of the page it said due to you
know UK law certain things have been
removed so I don't know if it was
exactly why I couldn't pull up a video
proving or tweets or anything because I
think using these words get stripped
from the social platforms I could not
prove to this man the member century in
that in the UK that this would use a VPN
and get around that uh yeah I mean at
the time I was just like trying to pull
it up and I'm like oh that's weird so
now you have someone who doesn't realize
he's a fan of a bigot because the law
has restricted the speech mmm
so there's a point to be made if you I
understand you want a healthy like you
you want Twitter to grow you need to
grow the shareholders needed to grow the
advertisers need to advertise so you've
got all these restrictions but allowing
people to say these awful things makes
sure we stay away from them and it
allows us to avoid certain people and
isn't it important to know that these
people hold these beliefs if you get rid
of them you know someone could walk into
a business and you wouldn't even know
that they were a neo-nazi but if they
were high-profile saying the things
you'd be like that's the guy I don't
like you're absolutely right this is
like one of my favorite sayings is that
sunlight is the best disinfectant mmm
and it's so so so true I like one of the
biggest problems with censorship is the
fact that you push people underground
and you don't know what's going on and
this is something I worry about it's not
that I don't worry about he banned
people for these reasons I also worry
about driving people away from the
platform and affecting their real lives
so like what we're trying to find this
right balance and I hear you like you
may not think we're drawing the lines in
the right place and we get that feedback
all the time and we're always trying to
find the right places
I worry as much about like the
underground and like being able to shine
a light on these things anything else
Tim I think it's a cost-benefit analysis
and we have to constantly rehash it and
do it like we we have the technology we
have today and we are looking at
technologies which open up the aperture
even more and we all agree that a binary
on or off is not the right answer and is
not scalable we have started getting
into nuance within our enforcement and
we've also started getting into nuance
with the presentation of of content so
you know one path might have been for
some of your replies for us to just
remove that those you know offensive
replies completely we don't do that we
hide it behind an interstitial to
protect the original tweeter and it and
and also folks who don't want to see
that they can still see everything they
just have to do one more top so that's
one solution ranking is another solution
but as technology gets better and we get
better at applying to it we have a lot
more option ality whereas we don't we
don't have that as much today I I feel
like you know it
just gonna reiterate an earlier point
though you know if you recognize
sunlight is the best disinfectant your
it's like you're chasing after a goal
that can never be met if you want if you
want to protect all speech and they
start banning certain individual you
want you want to increase the amount of
healthy conversations but you're banning
some people well how long until this
group is now offended by that group how
long till you've banned everybody I hear
you it I don't believe a permanent ban
promote self okay so I don't believe
that but we we have to we have to work
with the technologies tools and
conditions that we that we have today so
and evolve over over time to where we
can see examples like this woman at the
Westboro Baptist Church who was using
Twitter every single day to spread hate
against the other pzq a community and
over time we had I think it was three or
four folks on Twitter who would engage
her every single day about what she was
doing and she actually left the church
that's Michael Phelps she's amazing
and she's she's now pulling her family
out of that as well and you could make
the argument that if we banned that
account early on she would have never
left the church I completely hear that
we we get it it's it's just well so
let's I just want to make sure we're
advancing the conversation too and not
just gonna go back so I'll just ask you
this have you considered allowing some
of these people permanently banned it
back on with some restrictions may be
you can only tweet twice per day maybe
you can't retweet or something to that
effect I think we're very early in our
thinking here so we're open-minded to
how to do this I think we agree
philosophically that permanent bans are
an extreme case scenario and it
shouldn't be one of our you know
regularly use tools in our tool chest so
how we do that I think is something that
we're actively talking about today is
there a timeline that we can so so look
you know like that would fix a lot of
problems yes I really didn't if it's
like I'm just curious like are you
thinking like fans of a year or five
years ten years like I'm just curious
like what is what is a reasonable ban in
this kind of context well I I think
reasonably so much enough to state their
case as to why they want to be unbanned
like someone should have to have a like
a well measured considerate response to
what they did wrong do they agree with
what they did wrong maybe perhaps saying
wide
don't think they did anything wrong and
you could review it from there
I think you know one of the challenges
we have the benefit in English common
law of hundreds of years of precedent
and developing new rules and figuring
out what works and doesn't Witter is
very different so I think with the
technology I don't know if you need
permanent bans or even or even
suspensions at all you could literally
just I mean lock someone's account is
essentially suspending them but again I
wouldn't you know claim to know anything
about the things you go through but what
if you just restricted most of what they
could say you know you blocked certain
words in a certain dictionary if
someone's been if someone greased Hill
oh but no but but but the thing about
this way is it better to they're
permanently banned or better but it's
not it's not good you don't know think
about this way instead of being
suspended for 72 hours you get a
dictionary block from hate speech words
right does that not make sense people
just using coded language this is what
we see all the time yeah I know well
they could move what do you think about
perhaps instead of what is it possible
to have levels of Twitter like a
completely uncensored unmoderated level
of Twitter and then you know have like a
rate at are and then have like a pg-13 I
mean I don't think that's a bad idea we
we have those levels in place today but
you don't really see them one we have a
not safe for work switch which you can
turn on or off oh really
yeah I say four works which I think you
have it off Joe no it's there so we so
we have that and then as Richard pointed
out earlier you know we have the
timeline we we started ranking the
timeline about three years ago we enable
people today to turn that off completely
and see you know the reverse cron of
everything they follow you can you can
imagine a world where that switch has a
lot more power over more of our
algorithms throughout more of the
surface areas you can imagine that so
these are all the questions that are on
the table just about timeline and this
is this is a challenging one I don't
know about timeline because first we
we've decided that our priority right
now is going to be on proactively
enforcing a lot of this content
specifically around anything that
impacts
physical safety like like doxxing so
hi-brite but there's so many examples of
what you guys not doing that I I know
but that that's what we that's what
we're watching right now that's that's a
part is asian but i think from your
invective we think more in terms of
milestones on the particular time when
we're gonna move as fast as we can but
some of its a function of our of our
infrastructure of the technology we have
to we have to bring to bear do you guys
have conversations about trying to shift
the public perception of having this
left-wing bias and maybe possibly
addressing it yeah doing right now right
yeah i mean i went on the sean hannity
show I you know we how was that we
brought ourselves before it was
springing out of sunlight it was short
and he well it was short and there
weren't a lot of really tough questions
and that was a you know I I get it like
look again I'm also I'm from Missouri my
dad is a Republican he listened to
Hannity he listened the Rush Limbaugh my
mom was a Democrat and I feel extremely
fortunate that I was able to first see
that spectrum but also feel safe enough
to express my own point of view but when
I go on someone like Hannity I'm not
talking to Hannity I'm talking to people
like my dad who listen to him right and
I want to get across how we think and
and also that our thinking evolved 'z
and here's the challenges we're seeing
and like this art is our intent this is
what we're trying to protect and we're
gonna make some mistakes along the way
and we're going to admit to him we
didn't admit to them in the past we damn
it to a lot more over over the past
three years but you know I I don't know
any other way to address some of these
issues at all it all goes back to trust
like are one of our core operating
principles is earning trust how do we
earn more trust and I you know the
people in the world who do not trust us
at all and there are some people who
trust us a little bit more but this is
the thing that we want to measure this
the thing that we want to get better at
I saw you had a conversation with I
think Katie Hertzog no no who was it
that's the wrong person you had a
Twitter conversation with Oh Kara
Swisher Wow
wrong person but someone's got a shout
out and and you know I I see that the
left goes at you in the opposite
direction they want more can they want
more banning they want more you know
restrictions
the right is saying less right so I mean
in terms of solving the problem tell us
what that conversation was about I would
you want to summarize because because my
the thing I was pointing out
specifically was that you're being asked
to do more in terms of controlling well
it wasn't just more but to be a lot more
specific about what actions we've taken
to promote more health on the platform
like what products had we change what
policies did we introduced in the past
two years so she was asking questions
every question she asked she wanted me
to be a lot more specific and some of
these things have something that is very
specific some are a directional right
now because like we we have to
prioritize you know the direction and
and I talked about like you know we've
decided that physical safety is going to
be a priority for us and to us that
means like being a whole lot more
proactive around things like boxing so
choosing qestions I guess I'm not gonna
imply that you have unlimited funding
but we did mention the peer review oh
right right I mean you had mentioned
earlier layoffs in retraction
peer review which we mentioned but have
you just considered opening an office
even a small one for trust and safety in
an area that's not predominantly blue so
that at least you have like you can have
some pushback and is what is learned to
code mean and then they could tell you
absolutely so that that's a that's great
feedback and just so you know the trust
and safety team is also a global team
the enforcement team is a global team so
it's not like people from California who
are looking at everything making
decisions they're global now I hear your
point about who trains them and the
materials they have and all that and
like we have to think about that and
that's that's one thing that Jack has
really been pushing us to think about is
how do we decentralize our workforce
because out of San Jose out of San
Francisco in particular so this is
something he's very focused on what
about publishing evidence of wrongdoing
in a banning so when people say you know
what did Alex Jones really do maybe a
lot of people didn't realize what you
what you saw and again it's an issue of
trust yeah I I love this Tim I'm a
lawyer so by training we're thinking of
doing something called we call case
studies but essentially like this is our
case law this is what we use and so on
high-profile cases cases people ask us
about like to actually publish this so
that we can go through you know tweet by
tweet just like this because I think a
lot of people just don't
understand and they don't believe us
when we're saying these things so to put
that out there so people can see and
again they may disagree with the calls
that we're making but we at least want
them to see why we're making these calls
I think and that that I do want to do I
want to at least start that by the end
of this year so I think you know
ultimately my main criticism stands and
I don't see a solution to in that
Twitter is an unelected you know
unaccountable as far as I'm concerned
when it comes to public discourse you
have rules that are very clearly at odds
as we discussed I don't see a solution
to that and I think in my opinion we can
have this kind of like we've tone things
down we've had some interesting
conversations but ultimately unless
you're willing to allow people to just
speak speak entirely freely you are and
we have an unelected group with a near
monopoly on public discourse in many
capacities and I understand it's not
everything reddit is big to and it's you
know what I see is you are going to
dictate policy whether you realize it or
not and that's going to terrify people
and it's going to make violence happen
it's gonna make things worse you know
the the III I hate bringing up this
example on the rule for misgendering
because I'm actually I understand it and
I can agree with it to a certain extent
I've you know never liked nothing with
respect for the trans community but I
also recognize we've seen an escalation
in street violence we see a continually
a disenfranchised large faction of
individual in this country we then see
only one of those factions banned
we then see a massive multinational
billion-dollar corporation with private
and foreign investors and it looks to me
like if you hold if you know foreign
governments are trying to manipulate us
there I don't I don't see a direct
solution to that problem that you do
have political views you do enforce them
and that means that Americans who are
abiding by American rule are being
excised from political discourse and
that's the future that's it
yeah we do have views on the approach
and again like we we ground this in
creating as much opportunity as possible
for the largest number of people right
that's where it starts and where we are
today will certainly evolve but like
that that is what we are trying to base
our roles and judgments not and I get
that that's an ideology I completely
understand it but we we also have to we
also have to be free to experiment with
so
missions and experiment with evolving
policy and putting something out there
that might look right at the time and
evolving it I'm not saying this is it
but like we we look to research we look
to our experience and data on the
platform and and we make a call and if
we get it wrong we're we're going to
admit it and we're going to evolve it
but I guess do you you understand my
point I understand the point that there
there are American citizens abiding by
the law who have a right to speak and be
involved in public discourse that you
have decided aren't allowed to yeah and
and I think we've discussed like we we
don't see that as a win we see that as
not promoting health ultimately over
time right but it's ultimately what is
your priority
do you have it prioritized in terms of
what you've got what you guys would like
to change I think Jack has said it a
couple times but the first thing we're
gonna do is prioritize people's physical
safety that's got to be like
understanding you already I've done that
pretty much right no you do that more
okay work I don't think companies like
ours make the link enough buidling the
online and offline ramifications what's
the main criticism what's the main
criticism you guys is it censorship that
you guys experience is it censorship is
it banning like what is it what do you
get the most it depends on every single
person has a different criticism so I
don't think there's a universal opinion
I mean you just painted the picture
right I mean it like the left electrum
is asking for more sure the right is
asking for less but that's very
simplified just for this country mm-hm
yeah that's consistent I mean my opinion
would be as much as I don't like I don't
like a lot of what people say about me
what they do the rules you've enforced
on Twitter have done nothing to stop
harassment towards me or anyone else
right I swear to had my Twitter I mean
my reddit is probably you know 50
messages from various you know far left
and left-wing subreddits lying about me
calling me horrible names quote tweeting
me and these people are blocked right
and I never used to block people because
I thought it was silly because I can get
around it anyway but I decided to at one
point because out of sight out of mind
if they see my tweets less they'll
probably interact with me less but they
do this and they lie about what I
believe they lie about what I stand for
and there
trying to destroy everything about me
and they do this to other people I
recognize that so ultimately I say well
what can you do it's gonna happen on one
of these platforms the Internet is a
thing as they say on the Internet
welcome to the Internet so you know to
me I see Twitter trying to enforce all
these rules to maximize good and all you
end up doing is stripping people from
the platform putting them in dark
corners with a web where they get worse
and then you don't really solve the
Rassman problem hardly in a corner of
the web right right no I'm not talking
but there are dark corners I've read it
there where alternatives I mean the
internet isn't going to go away and
people have found alternatives and
here's the other thing that's really
concerning we can see a trend among all
these different big Silicon Valley tech
companies and they hold a similar view
to you guys they've banned similar
ideology and they're creating a parallel
society
you've got alternative social networks
popping up that are taking the dregs of
the of the mainstream and give them a
place to flourish grow make money now
we're seeing people be banned from
MasterCard from banned from PayPal even
banned from Chase Bank because they all
hold the same similar ideology to you oh
it's it's you know in some capacities I
don't know exactly why chase does it I
assume it's because you'll get some
activists who will explain what you're
talking about
there have been a series of individuals
banned from Chase Bank their accounts
have been yes their accounts were closed
one of the I think maybe the most
notable might be Martina and Marco de I
don't know much about her I follow
around Twitter and her tweets are
typical conservative fare and she
created a comic I think it's called Lady
alchemy
she's a trump supporter and she got a
notice that her business account was
terminated you then have Joe Biggs who
previously worked with Infowars I don't
know much about this I didn't follow up
but he tweeted out chases shutter my
account and then you have the new
chairman of the proud voice and wreak a
I forgot his last name tario or
something and so he knows really white
oh no he's a he's a for Cuban I know
that's letter I but you know so so what
I see across the board it's not just in
this where I want to bring it before
about perspective on these things
you guys are like we're gonna do this
one thing and no snowflake blames itself
for the Avalanche but now what do we
have we have conservatives being
stripped from PayPal we have certain
individuals strip from PayPal patreon
financing so they set up alternatives
now we're seeing people who have like
you mentioned Westboro Baptist Church
and
she's been d radicalized by being on the
platform but now we have people who are
being radicalized by being pushed into
the dark corners and they're building
and they're getting they're growing and
they're growing because there's this in
this idea that you can control this and
you can't you know I think you mentioned
earlier that there studies showing and
also counter studies but people exposed
to each other is better I found
something really interesting and because
I have most but whether or not people
want to believe this all of my friends
are on the left and some of them are
even like socialists and they're
absolutely terrified to say to talk
because they know they'll get attacked
by the people who call for censorship
and try to get him fired and when I
talked to them I was talking to a friend
of mine in LA and she said is there a
reason to vote for Trump and I explained
a very simple thing about Trump
supporters this was back in 2016 I said
oh well you know you got a lot of people
who are concerned about the free trade
agreements sending jobs overseas so they
don't know much about Trump but they're
gonna vote for him because he supported
that and so did Bernie and then the
response is really I didn't know that
and so you have this this ever-expanding
narrative that Trump supporters are
neo-nazis and the mob head is the KKK
hood and a lot of this rhetoric you know
emerges on Twitter but when a lot of
these people are getting excised then
you can't actually meet these people and
see that they're actually people and
they may be mean they may be mean people
they may be awful people but they're
still people and even if they have bad
opinions sometimes you actually I think
in most instances you find the regular
people well there's a part of the
problem of calling for censorship and
banning people and that it is sometimes
effective and that people don't want to
be thought of as being racist or in
support of racism or in support of
nationalism or any of these horrible
things so you feel like if you support
these bannings you support positive
discourse and a good society and all
these different things what you don't
realize is what you're saying is that
this does create these dark corners of
the web and these other social media
platforms evolved and have farm I mean
when you're talking about bubbles and
about these the these groupthink bubbles
the worst kind of groupthink bubbles is
a bunch of hateful people that get
together and decide their approach
they've been persecuted instead of like
we were talking about with Megan Phelps
having an opportunity to maybe reshape
their views by
having discourse with people yeah who
choose to or not choose to engage with
them well let's let's think about the
the logical end of where this is all
going you want healthier conversation so
you're willing to get rid of some people
who then feel persecuted and have no
choice but to band together with others
Master Card chaise patreon they all do
it Facebook does it they're growing
these platforms are growing they're
getting more users they're expanding
they're showing up in real life and
they're they're you know even if these
people who are band aren't the neo-nazi
evil they're just regular people who
have banded together that forms a
parallel finance system a parallel
economy
you've got patreon alternatives emerging
where people are saying you know we
reject you and now want a platform where
people say the most ridiculous things
now they have money who normalizes that
as well that's also blood that's what I
mean by a parallel society to them
everything they're doing is just and and
right and you can't stop them anymore
and it develops hate for the opposing
viewpoint you start hating people that
are progressive because these are the
people that like you and I have talked
about the date in society report that
labeled us is all right adjacent or
whatever now more fake news coming up
right connected because you and I have
talked to people that are on the right
or far right that somehow or another
we're secretly far-right and that
there's this influencer network of
people together and saying well it's a
schizophrenic connection that's one of
those weird things where people draw a
circle oh you talked to this guy and
this guy talked to that guy therefore
you know that guy well so so so here's
an expanded part of this problem so this
this you probably familiar but a group
called data and society published
what's entirely fake report labeling 81
alt right adjacent to wherever they want
to call it YouTube channels included Joe
Rogan and me it's fake but you know what
a couple dozen news outlets wrote about
as if it was fact you believe the proud
boys were labeled as FBI up by the FBI's
extremists when they actually weren't it
was a sheriff's report from someone not
affiliate with the FBI but they are
activists within media who have an
agenda and we saw this with learned to
code it was an NBC reporter who very
clearly is in you know left-wing
identitarian writing a story for NBC
then your average American sees that NBC
story thinks it's factual then everyone
talks about it then your people hear
about it then you start banning people
so you know that I guess them to drive
the point home the snowflake won't blame
itself for the Avalanche you guys are
doing what you think is right so is
Facebook YouTube patreon all these
all these platforms and it's all gonna
result in one thing it's gonna result in
groups like patriot pair and the proud
boys saying I refuse to back down
showing up it's gonna result in an tyfa
showing up it's going to result in more
extremism you've got an auntie of
account that published the home
addresses and phone numbers that hasn't
been banned that's going to further like
show conservatives that the policing is
asymmetrical whether you know it is or
isn't and I think the only outcome to
this on the current course of action is
like insurgency we've seen people
planting bombs in Houston try to blow up
a statue we saw someone plan to bomb at
a police station in Eugene Oregon two
weeks before that a guy showed up with a
gun and fired two rounds at a cop
wearing a smash the patriarchy and
sheíll shirt so you know so so that
happens then a week later they say you
killed our comrade then a week later a
bomb is planted I don't believe it's
coincidence maybe it is but because I
lived in New York I got out too many
people knew who I was and there were as
people sending me emails with threats
and I'm like this is escalating you know
we've seen throughout the past years
with Trump we've seen Breitbart has a
list of 640 instances of Trump
supporters being physically attacked or
harassed in some way there was a story
the other day about an 81 year old man
who was attacked and it seems like
everything's flowing in one direction
and nobody wants to take responsibility
and say maybe we're doing something
wrong right this is why that's why I
brought up early regulation is in my
opinion inevitable yeah I mean I don't
think it's going to be the
responsibility of any one company we we
have a desire to be clear that we have a
desire to promote health in in public
conversation and as we've said like I
don't think over time a permanent ban
promotes all right I don't but we we
have we have to we have to get there and
then the role of course but like we we
just have work to do and I the benefit
of conversations like this is we're
talking about it more but the people
will naturally call us out like you got
it you got to show it as well do you
feel regulation I don't I don't fear a
regulation if we're talking about
regulation in the government
intervention in the job of if a
regulator job is to protect the
individual and make sure that they level
the playing field and they're not pushed
by any particular special interests like
companies like ours
who might you know put work with a
regular to protect our own interest that
I think is incorrect I agree that we
should have an agency that can help us
protect the protect the individual and
level the playing field ID so I think
oftentimes companies see themselves as
reacting to regulation and I think we
need to take more of an education role
so I don't fear it I want to make sure
that we're educating regulators on
what's possible what we're seeing and
where we could go
when you say educating regulators that
that's initiating a regulation I mean
not necessarily I mean we might just be
educating regulators who are these
regulators these are folks who who might
be tasked with coming up with a proposal
for particular legislation or or laws to
present to legislators so it's making
sure that we are educating to the best
serve ability this is what we are this
is what we see this is where technology
is going and do you think you can hold
off regulation though you think that by
these approaches and by being proactive
and by taking a standard perhaps
offering up a road to redemption to
these people and making clear
distinctions between what you're what
you're allowing what you're not allowing
you can hold off regulation or do you
disagree with what he's saying about
regular I don't believe that should be
our goal is to hold off regulation I
believe we should be we should
participate like any other citizen
whether it be a corporate citizen or
individual citizen in helping to guide
the right regulation so are you familiar
and I could be wrong on this because
it's been like 15 years since I've done
this are you familiar with the Clean
Water Restoration Act at all I don't
expect anybody it's a very specific
thing so it was at some point in like
the early 70s there was a river in Ohio
and again I could be wrong it's been 15
years I used to work for an
environmental organization started on
fire and what was typically told to us
was that all of these different
companies said we're doing the right
thing but this as I mentioned the
snowflake doesn't blame itself so over
time the river was so polluted it became
sludge and lit on fire and so someone
said if all of these companies think
they're doing the right thing and
they've all just contributed to this
nightmare we need to tell them blanket
regulation
and so what I see with these companies
like banking institutions public
discourse platforms video distribution I
actually I'm really worried about what
regulation will look like because I
think the government is gonna you know
screw everything up but I think there's
going to be a recoil of first I think
the Republicans cuz I watched the
testimony you had in Congress and I
thought they had no idea what they're
talking about nor do they care there was
like a couple people who made good
points but the most part they were like
I or whatever and they asked about
Russia and stuff so they have no idea
what's going on but there'll come a time
when you know for instance one of the
one of the great things they brought up
was that by default when someone in DC
signs up they see way more Democrats
than Republicans right you remember that
when you testified yeah so well that
there's an issue and I don't think I
believe you when you say it's
algorithmic that these are you know
prominent individuals so they get
automatically recommended but then
they're you know so again the solution
to that like how do you regulate a
programmer to create an algorithm to
solve that problem is it's crazier
you're regulating someone to invent
technology but I feel like there will be
a backlash when too many right now we're
seeing the reason one of the reasons
were having this conversation is that
conservatives feel like they're being
persecuted and repressed so then it's
gonna escalate form it's not gonna stop
with the conversations and so that we've
been having a lot of talks about this
particularly around algorithms and one
of the things that we're really focused
on is not just fairness and outcomes but
also explained ability of algorithms and
I know Jack you you love the steps I
don't know if you want to talk a little
bit about our work there yeah I mean we
so there's two fields of research within
artificial intelligence that are rather
new but I think really impactful for our
industry one is fairness in ml so yes
and what fairness and machine learning
and deep learning so looking at
everything from what data set is fed to
an algorithm so like the training data
set all the way to how the algorithm
actually behaves on that on that data
set making sure that it it does not
develop bias over the large a longevity
of the algorithms use case so that's one
area that we want to lead in and we've
been working with some of the leading
researchers in the industry to do that
because the reality is a lot of this
human judgment is moving algorithms and
the the second issue with in moving
algorithms is
is our rhythms today can't necessarily
explain the decision-making criteria
that they use so they can't explain in
the way that you make a decision you
explain why you make that decision
algorithm today are not being programmed
in such a way that they can even explain
that you may wear an Apple watch for
instance it might tell you to stand
every now and then right now those
algorithms can't explain why why they're
doing that
right that's a bad example because it
does it every fit every 50 minutes but
as we offload more and more of these
decisions both internally and also
individually to watches and and and to
cars and whatnot there there is no
there's no ability right now for that
algorithm to actually go through and
list out the criteria used to make that
decision so this is another area that
we'd like to get really good at if we
want to continue to be transparent
around our actions because a lot of
these things are just black boxes and
they're being built in that way because
there's been no research into like well
how do we get these our rooms to explain
what their decision is that might and
hasn't been asked my fear is you it's
technology that you need to build yeah
but the the public discourse is there we
know that foreign governments are doing
this we know that Democratic operatives
in Alabama did this and so I imagine
that you know with Donald Trump III you
know he talked about an executive order
for free speech on college campuses so
that the chattering is is here someone's
going to take a sledgehammer to Twitter
to Facebook to YouTube and just be like
for not understanding the technology
behind it not willing to give you the
benefit but the benefit of the doubt and
just saying I don't care why you're
doing it we are mad you know I mean
there's a path some bills and and then
it's over again and clarifying I think
you guys are biased and I think what
you're doing is dangerous but I think
that doesn't matter that doesn't matter
what you think is right it matters that
all of these companies are doing similar
things and it's and it's and it's
already terrifying people
I mean look when when I saw somebody got
banned from their bank account that's
terrifying and PayPal has done this for
a long time you know that seems like
more egregious looting banned from any
social just or social media platform
that that seems to me to be worthy of a
boycott Patriot patreon issued a
statement about a man I believe his name
is Robert Spencer and they said
MasterCard instructed us to ban him
and you know what you don't say this to
me mentioning chase PayPal MasterCard
terrifies me I'm on the Joe Rogan
podcast right now calling out these big
companies in defiance and we've artists
I would like to know all the specifics
of why they chose to do that and I would
hope that they would release some sort
of a statement explaining why they chose
to do that maybe there's something we
don't know there was there was a
reporter and I could begin this wrong
cuz I didn't follow it very much with
big league politics who said that after
reporting on PayPal negatively they
banned him that's terrifying
so that's reporting on it in what way
like reporting on the sargon of akkad
issue no apparently is a journalist he
wrote about something bad PayPal did big
league politics is conservative and so
all of a sudden he got a notification
that they can't tell him why but he's
gone so I see these big tech monopolies
I see YouTube Facebook Twitter i see
PayPal MasterCard and they're doing it
and they all say they're doing the right
thing but all of these little things
they're doing are adding up to something
nightmarish and some some right
legislators gonna show up and in a
matter of time with a sledgehammer and
just he's gonna whack your algorithm
well it's really the same stupid logic
where I was talking about where you know
Gavin was saying punch people will you
punch people it doesn't end there
oh yeah ban them man it doesn't end
there doesn't end there yeah you have to
realize also twitter is how old now 11
years old 12 years old 13 years old 13
13 years old well 13 years from now one
of the odds that there's not gonna be
something else just like it well pretty
slim million no but let's let's talk
about the incestuous relationship that a
lot of these journalists have been
defending the policies you guys push gab
it was was was a study was done I talked
about this last time where they found 5%
of the tweet of the panel is a tweets
but the post on camp or hate speech
commanded Twitter's like 2.4 so it's a
marginal increase yet gab is called the
white supremacy Network
of course you go on it and yeah
absolutely exists they say that
synagogue shooter oh he was a gap user
he was a Twitter user too
he posted on Twitter all the time so why
the media is is targeting it's it's such
a crazy Samaras reality it is active
nerd when when the Guardian I believe
was the Daily Mail called count dank
EULA and Nazi hate criminal law that
literally made a joke on YouTube and
he's being he was arrested I thank God
every day we have the First Amendment in
this country well there's a cover of a
newspaper that was caught because he got
a job somewhere maybe he got fired for
that
he got kicked off the show Wow yeah
that's oh so you have cuz of try let me
let me ask you another thing do you guys
do you guys take the advice of the
Southern Poverty Law Center do we take
the advice of like so it's it's widely
circulated the SPLC lobbies various
social platforms to ban certain people
they advise it's been reported they
advised YouTube as is the
anti-defamation league did you use them
in your decision-making process it rule
development we're very aware of flaws
with certain of their research and we're
very careful about who we take advice
from but do you take advice from them um
I I think that they have certainly
reached out to our team members but
they're certainly nothing definitive
that we take from them we don't take
action you never take an action based on
information received from them so the
reason I bring them up specifically is
that they're cited often you know in the
United States there's other groups like
hope not hate in the UK and now they're
all gonna point there you know
figurative guns at me for saying this
but the Southern Poverty Law Center
wrote an article where they claimed I
went to Iran for a Holocaust deniers
conference and I've never been to Iran
and their evidence was this guy found an
archived website from a Holocaust denier
with my name on it and that was their
proof and there are people who have been
labeled you know extremists by this
organization that have been you Sam
Harris Sam Harris will start was yeah
didn't they lose a big lawsuit a
settling yeah so so again like not not
to imply that you guys do use it but I
asked specifically because it's been
reported other organizations do so we
have activist organizations we have
journalists that I can attest are
absolutely activist because I've worked
for I worked for vice I worked for
fusion I was told it implicitly not
explicitly to lie to side with the
audience as it were
I've seen the narratives they push and
I've had conversations with people that
I'm not gonna I'm gonna keep relatively
off-the-record journalists who are
terrified because they said the
narrative is real right one journalist
in particular said that he had yet
evidence of you know essentially he had
reason to believe there was a wrongdoing
but if he talks about it he could lose
his job and there there was a journalist
who reported to me that date and society
admitted the report was what was was was
incorrect and now you've got
organizations lobbying for terminating
Joe and I because of this stuff so this
this narrative persists then you see all
the actions I mentioned before and
the organization saying we're doing the
right thing and I gotta say like we're
living in it I mean I feel like we're
looking at the doorway to the nightmare
dystopia I I I just want to clarify like
I'd I don't I don't know if we're going
around saying we're we're necessarily
doing the right thing we're saying why
we're doing what we're doing right right
that's what we need to get better at and
I I don't want to hide behind what we
believe is like the right thing we have
to clearly rationalize why we're making
the decision we're making and more of
that that's that to me is the prevention
from this snowflake Avalanche metaphor
oh but but I think it's just obvious to
point out again I said this before we
can have the calm conversation and I can
understand you but for I'm from where
I'm sitting you hold a vastly different
ideology than I do and you have
substantially more power in controlling
my government that terrifies me and what
makes it worse is that a Saudi prince
owns a place was reported that Saudi
prince owns a portion of that company so
I'm sitting here like just a little
American can't do anything to stop it
I'm just watching this unaccountable
machine turn away and you're just one
snowflake in that avalanche all these
other companies are as well and I'm like
well here we go there's gonna be a riot
[ __ ] said that Saudi princes have any
influence but what am I supposed to
trust that that's that's the issue right
I'm not trying to insinuate he's showing
up to your meetings and telling you what
to do but when someone dumps a billion
dollars in your company I think it's
silly to imply that they don't at least
have some influence
regardless and unlike the internet
within a company like ours you don't
necessarily see the protocol you don't
see the processes and that's an area
where we can do a lot much right i s you
know beat it over the head a million
times be the dead horse I think
ultimately yeah I get what you're doing
I think it's wrong I think it's
terrifying
and I think we're looking we're we're
[ __ ] we're on the avalanche already it's
happened and we're heading down to this
nightmare scenario of a future where it
terrifies me when I see people who claim
to be supporting liberal ideology
burning signs that say free speech
threatening violence against other
people you have these journalists who do
the same thing they accuse everybody of
being a Nazi everybody of being a
fascist jokes and and you're like you're
like a socialist as far as I know you'll
at UVI proponent
you know I wouldn't necessarily say I'm
very being facetious I'm very liberal
and except for a second amendment that's
probably the only thing that I disagree
with a lot
and then you see what the media says
about everybody you see how they call
Jordan Peterson all day and night
alright y'all ready hates them and and
this narrative is used to strip people
of their income to remove them from
public discourse
well it's foolish because it in the
ultimately upon examination like you're
saying that sunlight is the best
disinfectant absolutely and upon
examination you realize that this is not
true at all and that these people look
foolish like the data in society article
no no no all these organizations publish
that as fact without looking at any
maybe some did but any dozens but yeah
and no no they still fighting about
millions and millions of people whose
who are these people that are still
citing it Guardian well class start
yelling shame but so so foolish we now
have and this mitten which makes things
muddy or is we now have a guy who's
claiming that he did and they're gonna
love this there's a guy claiming that
the eighty one accounts listed on this
thing is all trite have been are no
longer being recommended on YouTube and
so I looked at the the the statistics
for various people on this channel
because first of all my channel is doing
great my recommendations are way up as
are yours a lot of people are growing
and I did a comparison like subscribers
are up views are up what's this guy
claiming and apparently he did a big
sampling of videos where he for some
reason thought you Joe Rogan were twelve
percent of all videos in this network
and then when that when his data stopped
working he claimed that everything
stopped so he actually produced the
graph of primarily you at your channel
and then when his system stopped working
he published that and it was picked up
by Cena and now you have people claiming
the alt-right has been banned from from
YouTube and it's more fake news based
off fake news based off fake news I
don't understand what you're saying so
so basically there's a guy claiming that
because of data in society we have been
stripped of recommendations on YouTube
thank you I'll tell you one thing that
is true though we don't trend like Alex
Jones was saying like the video we did
got nine million views but it's not
trending and I said well it's because my
videos never trend they just don't trend
well here but I think it's probably
because of the language that's used I
think that's that's part of the issue
it's a subject matter in language I
think they have they have a bias against
swearing and and you know extreme topics
and subjects if I
I don't think that's true because you've
had like late-night TV hosts talk about
really messed up things they'll swear
wait they don't swear though that it's
not this it's not a matter of and what
they talk about whether that's messed up
in comparison what we talked about it's
probably pretty different you know I'm
in I'm uh I'm fairly resigned to this
future happening no matter what we do
about it
and so I bought a van and I'm gonna
convert it to us Christ well I'm coming
to a work station right you're gonna be
a prepper bro no no no no um first of
all I will say it's hilarious to me like
that people have band-aids they never
use but they don't store like at least
one emergency like food supply it's like
you never use mandates why do you have
them but no I I do I see this every day
it was a couple years ago I said wow I
see what's happening on social media
we're gonna see violence boom violence
happened I said oh it's gonna escalate
someone's gonna kill boom shots will
happen and it's like i-i've there have
been statements from foreign security
advisors international security experts
saying we're facing down high
probability of civil war and I know it
sounds crazy it's not gonna look like
what you think it looks like it may not
be as Extreme as it wasn't 1800s but
this was I think I think it was in the
Atlantic where they surveyed something
like ten different international
security experts who said based on what
the platforms are doing based on how the
people are responding one guy said it
was like 90% chance but the average was
really high well let's let's look
outside of the idea of physical war and
let's look at the war of information
what we're talking about what's
happening with foreign entities invading
social media platforms and trying to
influence our elections in our democracy
that is a war of information that is
that war is already going on if you're
looking at something like data in
society that's sort of an act of war in
that regard right it's an information
war an attempt to to lie to people it's
about their their ideological opponents
and it's also one of the woman who wrote
that said that it's been proven over and
over again the deep platforming is an
effective way to Cylons and then called
for us to be been yeah what's it's kind
of hilarious I don't think she was
saying that we should be banned I don't
think she said well she should be she
said something the affect of YouTube has
to take action to prevent this from you
know well you know people see someone
saying things that they don't agree with
it's very important for people to
understand we're silencing people leads
to and I don't think they do I think
people have these very simplistic
ideologies and these very very
narrow-minded perceptions of what is
good and what is wrong and I think and
I've been saying this over and over
again but I think it's one of the most
important things to state people need to
learn to be reasonable
they need to be learn to be reasonable
and civil discourse civil source is
extremely important and think over the
long term yes they understand it you're
playing chess yeah we did three hours
and 30 minutes then we nobody had a P
amazing view we did start a little late
yeah we're like 3:15 okay I mean I guess
the last thing I could say is I don't
think I think we had a good conversation
I think we did I honestly I don't think
we've solved anything I don't think
there's many any do you think we could
do this again like six months and see
where you guys are at in terms of like
what I think is important is the road to
redemption I think that would open up a
lot of doors for a lot of people to
appreciate you we're gonna need more
than six months here's the scary thing
the the information travels faster than
you can write that's the point I was
making the the our culture is going to
evolve faster than you can catch up to
that problem because there's a problem
and I don't well you know technology
took a big leap Twitter existed the
internet existed now we're all talking
so quickly you can't actually solve the
problem before the people get outraged
by it so no I can I mean there was an
early phrase in the internet by some of
the earliest in internet engineers and
designers which is code is law and a lot
of a lot of what companies like ours and
startups and random folks who are
individuals who are contributing to the
Internet will change parts of society
and some for the positive and some for
the negative and the most I think the
most important thing that we need to do
is to as we just said shine I'll punch a
light on it make sure that people know
where we stand and where we're trying to
go and what bridges we might need to
build from our current state to the
future state and and and be open about
the fact that like we're not going to
and this is to your other point we're
not going to get to a perfect answer
here like it's
just going to be steps and steps and
steps and steps and the what we need to
build is agility what we need to build
is an ability to experiment very very
quickly and take in all these feedback
loops that we get some feedback loops
like this um within the numbers itself
and then they integrate them much faster
what's wrong with the with the jury
system on Twitter why wouldn't that work
I don't know why I want to work on I'm
not saying we wouldn't test that yeah
like we're testing is our scope in in I
don't have a reason a compelling reason
why we want it do it with and Twitter
either I don't so we likely will but you
know again we were a company of so many
resources finite resources finite people
and and we need to prioritize and we've
decided you may disagree with this
decision but we've decided that physical
safety and the admission of off platform
ramifications is critical for us and we
need to be able to be a lot more
proactive in our enforcement which will
lead to stronger answers and we want we
want to focus on the physical safety
aspect and daxing is a perfect example
that has patterns that are recognizable
and then we can move on I I hear it and
I just feel like you know the conclusion
I can come to him the conversation is
you're gonna do what you think needs to
be done I think what you're doing is
wrong and ultimately nothing's gonna
change
I get it you're gonna you're gonna try
new technologies you're gonna try and do
new systems from the from where I see it
I think you have an ideology
diametrically opposed to mine I mean not
to an extreme degree I think there are
people who are more like I'm not
conservative there are a lot of people
who are who are probably think you know
I'll say this too you're a symbol for a
lot of them and so I can definitely
respect you having a conversation there
are so many different companies that do
things that piss people off you sitting
here right now I'm sure there's a ton of
conservatives who are pointing all of
their anger at you because you are here
but you know ultimately I just feel like
I don't think anything's gonna change I
think you're on your path you know what
you need to do and you're trying to
justify it and I'm looking at what
Twitter is doing as very wrong and it's
it's it's oppressive and ideologically
driven and I'm trying to justify why you
shouldn't do it but nothing's gonna
change mine my intention is to build a
platform that gives as many people as
possible opportunity to freely express
themselves and something
believe the Unites States has already
done that and Twitter is now going
against what the US has developed over
hundreds it doesn't have a platform I
mean the United States doesn't have a
platform to do that Twitter is the when
you're talking about the Internet the
United States if they want to come up
with the United States Twitter like a
solution on alternative that the
government runs and they use it use free
speech to govern that good luck good
luck with that once it's a huge
challenge and also I recognize it's not
just you you know almost insurmountable
I mean have the dummies that are in
charge of the United States government
this is why set regulation to is scary
yeah slide shits a terrible idea
but so but you know and I think it's
important to point out too that a lot of
people don't realize you guys have to
contend with profits you have to be able
to make money to pay your staff there's
no like you don't get free money to run
your company so aside from the fact that
you have advertisers want to be on the
platform I imagine a lot of these
companies are enforcing hate speech
policies because advertisers don't want
to be associated with certain things so
that creates you know through
advertisement cultural restrictions
that's a hundred percent the problem
right now hundred percent the problem
with most these platforms including
YouTube absolutely yeah I mean when the
PD pie thing happened and all of these
you know restrictions came down on on
advertising and content creators that's
where it comes from it comes from from
money it's why it does good just to be
clear those can be segmented as well
second guys advertisers can choose where
they want to where they want to be
placed certainly but the platform
recognizes there's a huge blowback and
they're losing money I mean look at the
the pedo scandal that just happened on
YouTube it was people posting comments
with timestamps they weren't even
breaking the rules and advertisers pull
up the platform and YouTube didn't
realize because they weren't breaking
the rules they're just creepy dudes so
maybe people yeah also they were putting
comments and so one of the most
preposterous responses to that was that
content creators gonna be responsible
for their comments
well they've written them off well the
problem with this ledge people like me
is that I put out a lot of content and
there's millions of views and it's
impossible to moderate on the comments
and we don't moderate them at all about
YouTube and only on videos with minors
so they deleted all comments
with mine yes videos when they say youth
but you know I'm saying if you put a
youtube video on you have a bunch of
people that say a bunch of racist things
in your YouTube comments you could be
held responsible and get a [ __ ] no no no
YouTube clarified that they clarified
that one that recently they said that
afterwards but the first initial
statement was that you were going to
response me up for your comments and
then I said it's [ __ ] michael like
philip defranco and a lot of people
freaked out and then they quality but so
the reason i bring that up is just
because there's gonna be things that
even if you segment your advertisers
from look you know I pointed out I think
the the Democrats are in a really
dangerous position because outrage
culture although it exists in all
factions is predominantly on one faction
and so when Trump comes out and says
something really offensive you know grab
them by the you know I'm talking about
the Trump supporters laugh they bought
t-shirts that said it the people on the
Left the Democrat types they got angry
so what happens now you see Bernie
Sanders he's being dragged the media is
looking for blood and they're desperate
they're laying people off they're dying
and they will do whatever it takes to
get those clicks there was enough like
you know as I have to do with Twitter
though it has to do with the fact that
someone's going to find something on
your platform and they're gonna call up
your advertiser and say look what
Twitter is doing and you're gonna be
like ah we had no idea and they're too
bad and cancelled all ads your money's
right up and so the reason I bring that
up is I recognize Twitter YouTube
Facebook these other platforms are
worried money has to come from somewhere
to pay people so you also have to
realize you've got the press that's
salivating looking for that juicy story
where they can accuse you of wrongdoing
because it'll get them clicks they'll
make money and that means even though
YouTube did nothing wrong with these
comments it was just a creepy group of
people who didn't break the rules who
figured out manipulate the system
YouTube a like YouTube had to take the
take that one the advertisers pulled out
YouTube lost money so YouTube then
panics sledgehammers comments just wipes
them out that cap in anybody right we're
in a really dangerous time with also in
their defense so they have to deal with
that I mean they have a bunch of
pedophiles that are posting comments I
mean what do you do about that what do
you know what other than hire millions
of people to moderate every single video
that's put on YouTube which is almost
impossible the point I'm trying to break
bring up is that even if Twitter wanted
to say you know what we're gonna allow
free speech what happens
advertisers are later even if you
segment it they're gonna be threatened
to buy it and so there was
actions are gonna come from whether or
not you can make money doing it I don't
know about that I don't know I I think
that that is changing and I think that
is changing primarily because the
internet if you look at what was
acceptable in terms of people discussing
that would get advertisement it was
network television standards now that's
changing I mean there's there's gonna be
there's ads on the line yeah yeah I put
out that have pretty extreme content
it's because advertisers are changing
their perspective but do you I don't
think so
they're shifting their hundred-percent
shifting that's why this this podcast
has ads sure sure I mean I don't think
it's it to the point where everyone's
lost all ads but I look you think George
Carlin will be allowed to do his bit
today yes no no come on man we're not
right you would be able to do it
listen there's stuff like that on
Netflix specials that are out right now
things are changing it's just in the
process of this transformation where
people are understanding that because of
the internet first if you look at
late-night conversations how about
Colbert saying that President Trump has
Putin's dick in his mouth how about him
saying that on television do you really
think that would have been done 10 years
ago it wouldn't have been 15 years ago
or 20 impossible not possible but you'd
Anders are changing because of the
Internet so things that were impossible
to say on network television just ten
years ago you can say that haven't Kevin
Hart lost his Oscar hosting gig because
10 years ago right but do you know why
he lost he lost it because people were
complaining right because people who
were activists were complaining that he
had said some homophobic things and they
don't every had subsequently apologised
for before they ever listened that count
count Daniel as a comedian okay look you
were to discuss this I'm with you and I
understand what you're saying comedian
but I'm a comedian and I understand
where things are going the the the
demise of free speech is greatly
exaggerated that's what I'm saying I'm
saying there's a lot of people out there
that are complaining but the problem is
not necessarily that there's so many
people that are complaining the problem
is that people are reacting to those
complaints right the vast majority of
the population is recognizing that there
is an evolution of free speech that's
occurring in our culture in all cultures
around the world but this is a slow
process that when you're in the middle
of it it's so almost like evolution well
you're in the middle of it you don't
think anything is
happening but it's [ __ ] happening oh
so yeah I agree with you I agree with
you that the majority of people are
alike that's funny I don't care but the
minority is kind of dictating things
right now for now they're not even
dictating things they're just making a
lot of noise and that that noise is
having an effect
that's what data in society was an
attempt at right I don't think it was
effective that's why we're still here
for talking right now it was one attack
articles that are written about all
sorts of things that are inaccurate or
and some people have been eating in a
bank accounts and some people up and
kicked up yes this is why it's important
to have this conversation right
conversations like this well so so
here's what I'll say I just I cross my
fingers and I wait for when you
implement block technology bro
well the van is going to be a mobile
production studio so I can travel around
when things are getting crazy a lot of
water know I'm putting more than just
band-aids I'm putting a shower in it
okay it's gonna be like a computer and
monitors and I'm gonna be able to do
video so I can travel around when
everything's happening but but I tape
this up I want to see the blockchain
version of Twitter where it's an exists
that's what I want to see it's gonna
happen whether we like it or not any
last thoughts no I just want to thank
you Joe has been great and Tim thanks
for your feel like you we're always
listening and I've learned a lot today
thank you I really appreciate you guys
thank you jack thank you any last things
no I think we've said it all that's a
wrap folks no more ear beatings
goodnight everybody
that was awesome thank you thank you
thanks for for chopped for talking I
really do appreciate it could you
and I so when so so when Lauren
something got banned from patreon hold
on a lot of people